Exzellent Leute, exzellent, exzellent. So, sind wir am Start. Oh, Teams, Moment, Teams hat Audio-Settings rumgewurstet.
Das stimmt wieder was nicht. Ey, das ist so eine scheiß Software. Was hat Microsoft denn da gebastelt? Das geht mir sowas von massiv auf den Sack, ey.
Echt unglaublich, vor allem, dass man das nicht abschalten kann. Versteh ich net. Ich reg mich da jedes Mal drüber auf, aber...
Ich wirklich Musik in dem Ordner? Na gut, was auch immer. Ich reg mich da jedes Mal drüber auf, dass Teams die Audio-Lautstärke vom Mikrofon umstellt. Das ist so nervig.
Und manchmal hör ich mich übelst kacke im Stream an, weil ich halt Homeoffice gemacht hab und telefoniert hab und Teams rumgestellt hab. Ich vergesse das vorher zurückzustellen.
Mating Gamer, drei Monate. Dankeschön für den Sub. Cute Subscription. Leute, ich glaube, ich bin nicht mehr normal im Kopf. Also jetzt ernsthaft, ne? Ich hab doch hier dieses Mikrofon am Start. Das alte hab ich. Also das, das...
Gibt's das überhaupt noch, das alte Blue Yeti? Das da. Ne, ja, also das, was man da sieht. Das da, das da. Das hab ich ja schon ne Weile am Start hier. Exakt das. Wobei das irgendwie silberner aussieht als das.
Aber ich warte jetzt erstmal, bis der Stream on ist, weil, glaub ich, Switch hat's noch nicht mitgekriegt. Die waren so beschäftigt, Pog zu removeen. Da kann schon mal dauern, bis der Stream on ist.
Wobei, es gibt ja... Habt ihr gesehen, Leute? Es gibt nen neuen Pogchamp. Guckt mal. Es gibt nen neuen Pogchamp. Die wollen jetzt... Guckt mal, es gibt nen neuen Pogchamp. Also wenn ich das richtig schreiben würde, dann...
Der, der... Sie wollen jetzt alle 24 Stunden nen neuen Pogchamp machen. Wo Prime. Richtig, gab ja schon den ersten Sub heute. Wobei ich den Pogchamp nicht gut find.
Heute vortransstreamen. Ne, ne. Heute muss ich paar Dinge einkaufen, die ich eh einkaufen muss. Und ich muss ein bisschen was erzählen. Ey. Also. Pass mal auf.
Pass mal auf. Ähm. Hentai Puppen shoppen. Wer shoppt da Puppen? Kissen. Kissen, wenn schon. So. Ähm. Wir hatten jetzt hier gesubbt. Da ist Freak. 14 Monate. Aber 14 Monate ist ja schon richtig... Hyper Subscription.
Und Eyong. Twitch Prime. Dankeschön. Guck mal. Das Scam Train. Kaum bist du da on. Kaum bist du da on ist das Scam Train am Start, Leute. Ihr werdet massiv jebaited wieder.
Aber lasst euch alle jebaiten. Lasst euch alle jebaiten. Und gebt mir Geld. Das find ich gut. Macht weiter. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich euch schon erzählt hab, dass man...
Wenn man den Sub Train auf Level 5 hat, dass man dann über 100% kommen kann. Wie weit bist du mit deinem Scraper? Gar nicht. Ich benutze jetzt ein anderes Projekt für.
Ähm. Warte mal. Shop. Street. Merchant. Github. Shot. Street. Merchant. Github. Das verwende ich jetzt das Ding. Das Scraped alle möglichen Sachen inklusive Alternate, Mind Factory, sonst was.
Hat schon Sachen eingebaut zum Umgehen von Cloudflare und alles. Und unterstütze Redis als Output. Ich dump jetzt... Ich lass quasi das Scrapen und dump mir den Output in Redis rein.
Das heißt, ich muss jetzt nur noch ein Webinterface bauen. Es wird ein neues Mic geben. Nee, ich muss euch jetzt mal was erzählen. Und zwar...
Ich hab ja seit Jahren dieses Mikrofon hier. Das kennt ihr wahrscheinlich noch aus. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das sogar mal gezeigt hab in einem Reveal gesehen.
Diese Videos, die machen mich immer wieder fertig. Oh, da ist er. Fuck, Alter. Das ist so geil.
Das ist 8 Jahre alt. Irgendwie seh ich genau so aus.
Warum ich das raus wollte ist... Also ich hab hier das Ploiety. Das habe ich ja schon bestimmt 8 Jahre lang, das Mikrofon. Ich hab's jetzt in letzter Zeit wenig benutzt.
Und ich wollte aber letztens mal wieder ein Video mit aufnehmen und mal gucken, wie sich das so anhört im Vergleich zu meinem Headset und sowas. Und ich hab's gesucht, ich hab's nicht gefunden. Leute...
Ich meine das ernst. Kein Chebat und nichts. Ich mach mir echt Gedanken, ob ich noch normal im Kopf bin. Und zwar... Ich hab's gesucht. Ich hab in den Schrank überall geguckt.
Ich hab hier in die ganzen Amazon-Kartons geguckt. Irgendwo war's. Hinterm Schreibtisch, hinterm Rechlein. Irgendwo war's. Und dann hab ich mir gestern oder vorgestern schon nochmal gedacht,
Hätte ich jetzt mal das Ploiety am Start und hab nochmal hier in meinem Arbeitszimmer rum geguckt, nochmal auf dem Schrank. Ich hab's nicht gesehen.
Heute Morgen steh ich auf und telefonier mit einem über Teams. Guck, ich steh so am Fenster, guck raus und ich guck rechts neben mir auf meinen Schreibtisch. Da steht's.
Kek Wait, ja. Das steht. Also jetzt hier neben meiner Tastatur ungefähr einen halben Meter am Schreibtischrand stand das einfach. So und man erkennt auch, dass es da wirklich schon eine Weile stand.
Weil an der Stelle... Ich mein, es ist jetzt nicht so als würde ich regelmäßig meinen Schreibtisch saugen. Da sind schon die ein oder anderen Krümel an manchen Stellen. Ja, könnte man sagen.
Und an dieser Stelle, wo das Mikrofon stand, wenn ich das hochhebe, ist einfach astreiner weißer Schreibtisch.
Das heißt, das stand da auch schon. Wirklich, da ist wie geleckt das Schreibtisch. Hier nebendran ist zum Beispiel ein bisschen Rand von der Tasse. Ja.
Hier vorne liegen auch ein paar Krümel rum, aber dort, wo das Mikrofon stand, genau so ein Kreis, wo das Mikrofon stand, nix. So und auf dem Mikrofon selbst hier unten ist auch schon recht viel Staub gewesen.
Das heißt, ich hab da auch seit zwei Jahren hatte ich das Ding da im Ende, da stand seit zwei Jahren auf meinem Schreibtisch und ich hab's net gefunden. Stealth Mikro... Ich hab da, jetzt ernsthaft Leute, ich hab da durchgeguckt.
Ich hab nämlich sogar, weil hinter dem Mikrofon steht die Xbox und die Playstation auf so einem kleinen Tisch drauf und ich hab sogar mich da drüber geborgen, hab hinter die Konsolen geguckt, da stell ichs manchmal hin, weil da ist Platz.
Da stell ich manchmal Zeug hin, was ich hier brauche, aber nicht direkt. Und ich kann kaum hinter meinen Monitor oder hinter die Konsolen gucken, ohne dass ich dieses Mikrofon berühr.
Also das hatte ich als, ohne Mist, das hatte ich noch nie, dass ich so, so blind war. Also das hat mich jetzt wirklich, jetzt lacht ihr mich aus ja, aber das hat mich wirklich heute zwei Stunden beschäftigt und ich wollte das nicht wahrhaben, dass das die ganze Zeit schon da stand.
Ich hab sogar Fotos davon gemacht, ob da irgendwelche Fingerabdrücke drauf sind oder sowas. Wer weiß, wer weiß, wer weiß, ja. So High-Res Fotos und hab geguckt und alles, es war halt gleichmäßiger Staub drauf, so ein bisschen halt auf den Stellen wo ich einen Finger drauf hatte vorher nicht.
Ey ganz merkwürdig Leute, ganz ganz komisch. 5G war das, ja das wirds sein. Das hat mich heute echt verwirrt, ja sag ich euch, kein Scheiß.
Das hat mich richtig verwirrt. Nee eher nicht. Weiß nicht wie gut das Ding ist, aber ich glaube nicht, dass das Ding so nice ist.
Die Katze war es, ja. Ich hab gesagt stop nicht, dass das so geil ist das Ding. Ja, geht sogar. So beschissen ist es dran.
Wie ist das so im Vergleich? Also ja, die ein oder anderen Sachen kannst du da wahrscheinlich schon mitspielen. Also rein zum Spiel würde ich es mir halt nicht kaufen. Zum Spiel findest du sicherlich besseres.
Ja naja, also da drauf kann man mit Sicherheit das ein oder andere spielen, wenn jetzt auch nicht irgendwie wahrscheinlich nicht in High oder so. Ich kann es jetzt schlecht sagen wie sich das Quadro Ding schlägt, aber scheint ganz ok zu sein.
Nee aber Leute ohne Scheiß, das hat mich echt verwirrt heute. Ihr könnt euch das gar nicht vorstellen. Ja wenn es, kannst du da auf jeden Fall drauf spielen. Ich mein Battlefield 3, das ist von 2011, das läuft auf meinem Klo.
Also wenn der Displayport hätte, würde es auf meinem Klo laufen. Battlefield 5 bestimmt auch. Der Desktop ist POG. Der Chat mag meinen Desktop, ich weiß das. Der sieht ja auch nur wegen dem Chat so aus. Guck mal aus, was besteht das aus 30 Milliarden Emotes, die ich nur hinzugefügt habe, dass ich sie als Overlay verwenden kann.
Nicht Qt Chat, das ist Qt Desktop.
Oder außerdem, ich finde ja da sofort alles drauf. Was weiß ich, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie, ja gut ich kann es schlecht sagen, was ich suche. Five Head, Five Head. So Bam, da.
Können wir uns Ruby 3.0, ja können wir machen. Das ist nämlich erst letztens rausgekommen. POG Champ wurde entfernt, ja das ist ja schon Old News.
Aber auf Ruby 3, das kam ja letzten Weihnachten raus, also vor zwei Wochen oder so. Da bin ich wirklich sehr gespannt drauf, das gucken wir uns auf jeden Fall im Stream an. Ich glaube das habe ich sogar schon hier reingeschrieben. Ruby 3.0, Ruby. Der Scheiß Knopf. Ja das finde der Chat toll, das weiß ich. Die Story musste ich bestimmt auch schon 20 mal erzählen und alle freuen sich dabei immer.
Also Leute, wenn ihr was wissen wollt, schießt los. Ich habe heute außerdem ein paar Sachen einkaufen, nichts vor. Ich muss jetzt erstmal den Stream anmachen, dass ich mir nicht noch weiter Gedanken um ein komisches Mikrofon mache.
Glaubt mir Leute, es ist wirklich verwirrend. Wäre die Polizei zu mir gekommen und hätte gesagt, Max sie müssen, keine Ahnung, theoretisch so, was weiß ich, sie müssen schwören vor Gericht, dass dieses Mikrofon da bis heute nicht stand. Ich hätte gesagt, ja.
Wo wir mal wieder, wo wir mal wieder sind, dass man sich auf solche Zeugen aussagen nicht verlassen kann. Wie gesagt, hättet ihr mich gefragt heute Morgen, ich hätte geschworen, dieses Mikrofon ist seit mindestens drei Wochen nicht auf meinem Schreibtisch gewesen.
Das hätte ich ernst gemeint, ja. Anscheinend war es da, andere Erklärungen gibt es ja nicht für. Kannst du mir einen Monitor empfehlen? Full HD würde mir reichen, also ich kann dir den sagen, den ich habe. Ich habe einen BenQ X.
Hab ich den? Ich kann mir das immer nicht merken. Wenn es davon eine neue Variante gibt, es, ja. Also ich hab den, den würde ich aber so nicht mehr kaufen, weil da gibt es jetzt gerade ganz neu einen Refresh von, nämlich
Ja, gute Frage. K, K, genau. So.
Jaja, ich hab das Mikrofon hier, ich hatte meinen Ploieti. Ploieti stand, das Mikrofon stand die ganze Zeit auf dem Schreibtisch, ich hab es nicht gesehen, ich hab es seit drei Wochen gesucht.
Also sag mal mal so, ich hätte heute Morgen noch geschworen, es ist nicht auf dem Schreibtisch, aber ich hab es, es stand einfach da und ich wüsste nicht, wie es sonst hingekommen sein soll. So, und das ist, wie gesagt, ich hab den Vorgänger davon, den gibt es als erstes seit einem Monat und ich finde den wirklich nice.
Ja, der hat was, allerdings ist der ein bisschen teurer, aber wenn man einen Gaming-Monitor sucht, finde ich den wirklich sehr gut. Gleich mal RefLink generieren. Maus-Tastatur kann ich gleich was sagen. Also, Deep in Linux finde ich super, wenn man damit klarkommt, dass es eine China-Distro ist, aber ich finde es gut.
Äh, nee, Battlefield 3 für kostenlos gibt es nicht mehr, das gab es nur bis Ende Dezember, aber einlösen kannst du es bis Ende Januar oder du kaufst dir einfach bei irgendeinem Keyshop für 2,50 Euro was.
So, also den hier finde ich gut, wie gesagt, ich hab den S, den Vorgänger, aber die werden da nicht so viel geändert haben, gehe ich da, wir kommen jetzt mal an, Differences, was es da Unterschiede gibt.
Moment, gibt es das doch nicht den neuen? Doch, genau, es kam vor einer Woche raus.
Ja, und zu dieser Einsage mit 240, äh, whoops, hallo, chat, please, äh, ja, lohnt sich, lohnt sich. Die Seitenteile musst du nicht dran machen, kann ich dir mal die Bilder zeigen.
Also das hat so Seitenteile für die krassen eSport Tournament Competitive Dudes, aber die musst du nicht dran machen, die hab ich auch nicht dran, die hab ich auch nicht dran.
Manche Leute mögen das, manche machen es, dass man nicht abgucken kann, manche machen es zum besseren fokussieren und weil was mit dem Typ hier abgeht, ist mir auch nicht ganz klar.
Ich hab, ich hab dieses Werbevideo dazu gesehen und der Typ, der hat ja wirklich die Augen im Monitor.
Ich mein, the fuck, was ist mit dem Kerl auf der rechten Seite los?
Hey, ich hab, ich hab ne ganze Zeit lang ziemlich viel Starcraft geguckt und selbst die koreanischen Starcraft Pro sitzen nicht so da.
Habt ihr, habt ihr schon irgendwann mal nen eSport Menschen gesehen, der wirklich so da sitzt?
Ich mein, das funktioniert doch überhaupt nicht, der sieht doch gar nicht was rechts unten oder links unten auf dem Monitor passiert von ihm aus.
Woran ich mein Headset Mikrofon angeschlossen hab, an so nem Mini Behringer Mixer und den Rest hab ich über ein anderes Autointerface laufen.
Ja, das ist schwachsinnig, also beides ist wirklich schon hochgradig bescheuert.
Dieses schräg machen tatsächlich welche, also wenn man sich CS Tournaments anguckt, gibt es wirklich manche, die haben ihren Kram so schräg.
Ja, zumindest der ist, der ist ganz nice und ich find der Unterschied zwischen 120 bzw. 144 und 240, das lohnt sich, aber das ist nicht so groß, das ist nicht so groß, ich find das so geil, Alter.
Das ist nicht so groß wie zwischen 60 und 70.
Was jetzt ganz cool ist, du kannst deine Settings sharen, wenn du das mal woanders aufbaust, aber das brauchst du normalerweise nicht.
Deswegen alle zusätzlichen Features, die die in diesem Video zeigen zu diesem Monitor, finde ich jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig toll, dass es sich rechtfertigen wird, einen neuen Monitor zu kaufen.
Deswegen würde ich einfach mal von ausgehen, es ist nicht so groß wie zwischen 60 und 140.
Deswegen würde ich einfach mal von ausgehen, es ist mehr oder weniger der gleiche Monitor, den ich mir letztes Jahr gekauft habe, mit einem minimalen Upgrade.
Der hat 240, der hat 240 und ehrlich gesagt, ich glaube sogar auch noch G-Sync, wenn man das braucht.
Oder FreeSync oder so.
G-Sync, aber braucht man eh nicht, who cares, G-Sync, Alter. Ja, wie gesagt, den kann ich empfehlen.
Und, ach guck mal, den gibt es auch mit 144, da ist er kostet nur die Hälfte.
Wenn schon würde ich wirklich den kaufen hier.
Also ich finde, für mich ist 24,5 Zoll optimal, aber ich kenn auch genug, die sagen, ich bin zu klein, 27 Zoll.
Aber ich mag es vom Abstand her, mag ich 24,5 Zoll.
Und der Unterschied ist natürlich nicht so groß, aber ich finde, man merkt es.
Und was tatsächlich gar nicht so schlecht ist, ist diese, diese, was ist das?
Weiß ich nicht, auch die die Eck oder so.
Die machen zwischendurch den Bildschirm schwarz, die Hintergrundbeleuchtung aus.
Und dadurch simuliert das so ein bisschen das, was du bei einem Röhrenmonitor hattest.
Röhrenmonitor ging ja auch automatisch prinzipbedingt aus zwischendurch.
Und deswegen haben die ja übrigens auch geflimmert.
Das ist ja der Grund, warum Röhrenmonitorer geflimmert haben.
Mit Schrei im Chat, falls euch das mal einer fragt.
Und das simulieren die damit ein bisschen.
Und das sorgt dafür, dass bei schnellen Drehungen die Sachen noch schärfer sind.
Ich kann euch nicht genau sagen, ob das wirklich Placebo-Effekt ist oder nicht.
Aber ich bilde mir ein, das bringt was.
Also Whoop Note bräuchten wir glaube ich auch noch als, als Emote.
So, dann gehen wir nochmal schnell auf die andere Frage ein.
Irgendjemand hat noch gefragt, was ich für Maustastatur verwende.
Also nachdem ich jetzt einige Mäuse die letzten Jahre durch hatte.
Und mich an den meisten immer irgendwas gestört hat.
Bin ich jetzt hängen geblieben bei einer Logitech, äh, was ist?
Da ist einfach nur Pro drauf.
Logitech Pro Wireless.
G Pro Wireless glaube ich, ja.
Jetzt bin ich bei so einer hängen geblieben.
Das ist meine erste Wireless-Maus.
Nee, PogChamp ist nicht weg, PogChamp ist jetzt ein anderer PogChamp.
So, also das Teil habe ich als erste nicht wired, Wireless.
Warum ist die Musik jetzt auf einmal so laut?
Kannst du wieder nicht entscheiden, ne?
Und das ist die erste Wireless-Maus, die ich habe.
Ich muss sagen, ich merke keinen großartigen Unterschied.
Und das ist Pog.
Wirklich nice.
Ich hatte die Jahre über davor.
Ich hatte eine Logitech, die, die, diese dicke.
Logitech, äh, Spectrum.
Hier, G502.
G502 hatte ich.
Die war mir zu schwer.
Dann hatte ich eine Zoey EC2A oder sowas.
War mir auch zu schwer.
Dann habe ich, oh, da habe ich schon wieder vergessen.
Dann hatte ich noch zwei Logitechs.
Und jetzt bin ich bei der hängen geblieben.
Die G502 ist mir zu schwer gewesen.
Eine G, eine G, ähm, 402 oder 403 hatte ich noch.
Genau.
Pass mal auf, Gewicht.
Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Der Unterschied ist tatsächlich kaum, kaum vorhanden.
Guck mal hier, ähm, Gewicht.
Okay, das ist anscheinend eine ganz neue.
G502 Pro Protoscore.
Das war die erste.
Gewicht.
128 Gramm.
G Pro Wireless-Gewicht.
80 Gramm.
Also der Unterschied, 80 Gramm zu 128 Gramm.
Das merkste.
Die hier ist relativ leicht.
Die ist easy, ja.
Ist überhaupt kein Ding.
Aber die G502, die war mir zu schwer.
Auch selbst ohne Gewichte.
Du konntest ja in die, du konntest ja in die G502.
Da kannst du ja noch unten Gewichte rein machen.
Guck dir an, unten noch Gewichte gehabt.
Die konntest du richtig, richtig fett machen, die Maus.
Ich wusste auch, wüsste auch gar nicht, wozu man da die Gewichte rein machen soll, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Vielleicht, wenn man, vielleicht wenn man ultra heiß senset oder so.
Dass man, dass man nicht, dass man vielleicht, ich hab keine Ahnung, ehrlich gesagt.
Echt keine Ahnung, ist mir auch egal.
Also jetzt hab ich, ja also wie gesagt, das ist aber auch eine äußerst subjektive Geschichte.
Da gibt es nichts besser oder schlechter.
Der einzige Maßstab, den es gibt bei Maus Setup und Gewicht.
Also das einzige wirkliche, was man, was man als Maßstab rannehmen kann, ob es gut oder schlecht ist.
Ist, ob die Person, die vorm Rechner sitzt, ihre Shots trifft oder nicht.
Das ist das einzige.
Ist scheiß egal, ob du high sens, low sens, kabellose Maus, Kabelmaus, schwere Maus, leichte Maus.
Ob du im Handstand auf dem Kopf, auf dem Klo spielst, ist vollkommen egal.
Du musst treffen.
Wenn du nicht triffst, solltest du dir vielleicht mal überlegen, ob du an einem Setup was änderst oder einfach schlicht und klar üben musst.
Oder wenn du triffst, ist alles gut.
Wunderbar, ich glaub, da muss man sich gar nicht mehr Kopf drum machen, als es letztendlich ist.
Man wird sicherlich in allen Games Leute finden, die ein bisschen schneller spielen und ein bisschen langsamer spielen.
Natürlich ist es in Games wie CS so, dass die Leute tendenziell alle ultra low sens spielen, aber auch da gibt es Unterschiede.
Es gibt manche, die brauchen einen halben Schreibtisch zum Drehen.
Es gibt manche, die brauchen nur einen Viertelschreibtisch zum Drehen.
Und wenn du dir dann so was anguckst, wie Leute, die Quake spielen oder Spiele, die ein bisschen mehr Movement brauchen, da ist es natürlich höher.
Aber du wirst es in jedem Game finden, Leute, die es halt unterschiedlich mögen.
Gerade in Overwatch war es auch von Held zu Held unterschiedlich, was du gespielt hast.
Hast du was Movement-Intensives gespielt, hast du halt möglichst was genommen, wo du jetzt nicht...
Dann schreib dich durch Scharps dabei.
Und hast du irgendwas auf Long Range mit Aiming gespielt, dann musstest du halt ein bisschen langsamer stellen.
Deswegen, für Overwatch fand ich es echt cool, dass man in der Logitech Software, kann man wahrscheinlich in jeder anderen Maus auch,
dass man die Buttons custom belegen konnte, also auch hier mit der G Pro Wireless.
Dass du Sens-Hochsens runter machen kannst, kannst du hier irgendwo hier drauf legen, wie du lustig bist.
Und das ist tatsächlich ganz nützlich.
Da kannst du hier einschalten, was ich mache, hier machst du 800 DPI, hier machst du 1200 DPI.
Das ist tatsächlich ganz nice.
Oder manche finden ja schon alles über 400 zu viel.
Aber wenn du beispielsweise Lucius Support spielst, da musst du schon ein bisschen mehr machen, als wenn du ein bisschen was anderes...
Ist ja auch egal jetzt.
Also deswegen finde ich die Funktion eigentlich ganz gut.
Gut, so viel dazu.
Warum nicht diese Maus? Gucken wir mal.
Ich traue dir jetzt mal, dass man das aufmachen kann.
Oh, exzellent.
Die brauche ich, die Maus.
Direkt gekauft.
Ganze zwei Euro, die ist ja...
Das ist mir zu teuer.
Das kostet mir zu viel für zwei Euro.
Kostenloser Versand.
Kein Yau.
Super Economy.
30 bis 50 Tage.
Also guck mal, wenn Super Economy schon so lange braucht...
Also nein, wenn Super Economy Global schon 30 bis 50 Tage braucht, wie lange braucht denn dann Super Economy?
Ich schätze die, ja 18 der 3., im März, im März kommt die.
Im März.
70 Tage.
Bis dahin ist der AliExpress Typ wieder aufgetaucht.
Ich habe in irgendeinem News Artikel gelesen, da ist verschwunden der AliExpress Mann.
Der Alibaba, in dem das gehört.
Hatte der nicht irgendwelche Steuerprobleme in China?
Ich habe es so am Rand irgendwie so mitgekriegt, aber das ist ganz schön langer Versand.
Ach, Lieferung bis 28 der 3., das dauert Länge und dafür sollst du noch mehr bezahlen.
Der hat was gegen die Regierung gesagt. Ah, okay, das ist in China gefährlich.
Das würde ich in China auch nicht machen.
Gerade, gerade, guck mal, es ist den Baro Maus für dich.
Also gerade in China und wenn ich da noch irgendjemand bin, der in der Öffentlichkeit steht,
da ist es taktisch eher ungeschickt, sich zu äußern zu solchen Sachen.
Auf der anderen Seite, ich meine hier verschwindest du nicht einfach,
aber wenn du hier die falschen Sachen sagst, hast du auch teilweise zurecht Probleme.
Guckt euch, bestes Beispiel, gerade aktuell, hat mit der eigentlichen Plattform nichts zu tun,
aber Mr. Pogchamp hat sich in politischer Art und Weise geäußert, wie das quasi seinem,
na gut, Arbeitgeber ist es nicht, wie das seinem, wie das Twitch nicht gefallen hat.
Und nachdem Twitch hier komplett machen kann, was sie wollen, haben sie gesagt,
nö, den Kerl wollen wir nicht mal als Team Out haben.
Was ich verstehen kann, erstens Twitch kann machen, was sie wollen auf der Plattform.
Können sie faktisch, selbst wenn es die Regel nicht hergeben,
ich finde auch, dass die Regel nicht sonderlich nachvollziehbar ausgelegt werden.
Was hat er gesagt?
Der hat irgendwas erzählt über diese Frau, die diese da in den USA im Kongresskapitol erschossen haben.
Hatte irgendwas erzählt über irgendwie Märtyrer und sonst was.
Ein bisschen komisches Zeugs, ja, muss ich auch sagen.
Und ja, zumindest hat Twitch gesagt, wollen wir nicht, wollen wir nicht und haben ihn gekickt.
Wobei ich halt sagen muss, ich bin da ein bisschen Zwiegespalten, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Ich kann es verstehen, dass Twitch das macht.
Das leuchtet mir ein.
Twitch, letztendlich geht es Twitch ja unterm Strich auch nur darum, um Kohle zu verdienen.
Und die machen alles, was man machen muss, dass ihr Image quasi unbeschädigt bleibt.
Ja, was meint ihr denn, warum die ganzen Firmen, sei es jetzt Activision oder sonst was,
warum die sich alle so ausgelassen haben zu Black Life Matters
und auf der anderen Seite zu Geschichten in Hongkong nichts gesagt haben.
Natürlich könnte man jetzt sagen, ja, okay, das eine ist vor der Haustür und das andere ist weit weg.
Das hat mit Sicherheit auch eine große Rolle gespielt.
Aber ich bin mir da ziemlich sicher, dass man genau abgewegt hat.
Man darf nicht vergessen, letztendlich unterm Strich wollen die Geld verdienen.
Die haben das genau abgewegt.
Die haben gesagt, hey, sagen wir jetzt was zu Hongkong, dann mögen uns die Chinesen nicht mehr
und wir können unseren Kram in China nicht kaufen, nicht verkaufen.
Und bei Black Life Matters haben sie das.
Okay, die öffentliche Stimmung geht jetzt eher so in die Richtung.
Deswegen sagen wir jetzt was zu.
Man darf nicht davon ausgehen, dass sie das ernst meinen.
Also das habe ich mir abgeschminkt, dass man Aussagen von solchen Firmen in irgendeiner Art und Weise,
beispielsweise Activision, von irgendeiner Art und Weise ernst nehmen muss.
Das heißt, die machen das, die machen das, was sie für sich am besten erachten, unabhängig davon irgendwelchen Moralvorstellungen.
Das heißt, das ist vollkommen bescheuert anzunehmen, dass die quasi das eine gut finden und das andere schlecht.
Die finden nur das gut, wovon sie denken, dass es sie besser dastehen lässt.
Das ist alles. Denke ich zumindest darüber.
Und wie bin ich jetzt eigentlich drauf gekommen?
Keine Ahnung. Irgendwie von der Cute Mouse. Irgendwie bin ich von der Cute Mouse da drauf gekommen.
Keine Ahnung.
Was? Es gibt keinen Post Champ mehr?
Ernsthaft? Wo ist der?
Warum ist der Post Champ weg?
Moment.
FFZ hat die entfernt?
Wirklich?
Dann mach ich den dann wieder über Bella Twitch TV rein.
Kack wie.
Ich mach den jetzt über Bella Twitch TV rein, Mann.
Genau. Und, ähm, Add to Channel, Add to Personal. Exzellent.
Genau. Und, ähm, deswegen, ich kann das, ich kann das komplett nachvollziehen.
Twitch hat auch alle Rechte da auf ihrer Plattform das zu machen.
Ich kann es auch verstehen, dass Twitch gesagt hat, sie wollen den Kell nicht mehr als Gesicht von einem Emote haben.
Alles in Ordnung, kann ich voll nachvollziehen.
Wobei ich ja halt persönlich sagen muss, meine persönliche Ansicht ist, ähm...
Mich interessiert es jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht so sehr, was ein Emote, was die echte Person hinter einem Emote macht.
Ich wusste vorher nicht, was das für ein Typ ist.
Ich habe da aber auch nicht reininterpretiert, dass das irgendwie jetzt der Engel auf Erden ist oder so.
Mir war es ehrlich gesagt egal, was das für ein Typ ist.
Das war für mich der Pokchamp-Mann.
Das war für mich keine echte Person in dem Sinne, das war der Pokchamp-Mann.
Und, ähm, mir war es ehrlich gesagt auch vollkommen egal, was der Pokchamp-Mann macht, denkt oder tut.
Das heißt, aus meiner, also für mich hätte man das jetzt nicht machen müssen.
Ich fühle mich jetzt nicht besser, nur weil der alte Pokchamp weg ist.
Aber ich kann es verstehen, ich kann es verstehen.
Twitch und genauso gut Amazon, YouTube, Google, an alle versuchen natürlich so Sachen zu umschiffen,
dass sie halt möglichst gut dastehen.
Und das Beste, was man machen kann, ganz im Ernst, ich sage es nur nochmal, ich habe es jetzt schon oft gesagt,
es hat keinen Sinn zu fanboyen.
Man darf nicht von ausgehen, dass Activision oder Amazon oder YouTube oder irgendwie was, was im Sinne der Leute macht, die fanboyen.
Für die sind Fanboys einfach nur, ähm, so willige Cash Cows erst mal.
Und umso besser, umso mehr Fanboys es gibt, umso einfacher kommt man mit irgendeinem Bullshit durch.
Jetzt nicht auf Pokchamp bezogen, nur allgemein.
Also Fanboyer hat keinen Sinn.
Ich persönlich bin auch Twitch Fanboy, ich bin der Meinung, das ist die beste Livestreaming Platform, die es gibt.
Ich weiß, ich bin Partner, ich muss das sagen, aber ich habe das glaube ich nicht unterschrieben, dass ich das sagen muss.
Deswegen bin ich auch hier, ich finde es gibt nichts Vergleichbares zu Twitch.
Und ich finde auch Twitch ist bei weitem nicht so schlecht, wie es in letzter Zeit gemacht wird.
Es ist ja, an allen Ecken sind sie sich über Twitch am Aufregen.
Ich kann das auch zum Teil nachvollziehen.
Was ich, was ich an Twitch, also es gibt eigentlich nur eine Sache, die mich an Twitch echt nervt.
Und das ist die nicht nachvollziehbare Auslegung von Guidelines und Regeln.
Wenn ich mir angucke, dass sich eine Streamerin hinstellen kann, sich quasi...
Chat, ich könnte mir vorstellen, der eine oder andere von euch hat es gesehen.
Ja, sich vor die Kamera stellen kann, die Hose runter ziehen kann, sich nach vorne beugen kann.
Und sagt man mal, etwas tiefere Einblicke gewährt vor der Kamera, live auf Twitch.
Dann gibt es einen 3 Tage Bann.
Was meint ihr denn?
Was meint ihr denn, was los gewesen wäre?
Jetzt überlegt euch mal, nur mal rein theoretisch.
Stellt euch vor, ich hätte einen OnlyFans Account.
Also, übrigens die Erklärung war, die Erklärung war, und das kann auch gut sein.
Ich glaube auch nicht, dass sie das absichtlich gemacht hat oder so.
Die Erklärung war ja, sie wollte ein OnlyFans Video aufnehmen und hat auf jeden Fall live streaming gedrückt.
So, und jetzt stellt euch mal vor, ich hätte einen OnlyFans Account.
Und ich hätte meine Kamera angemacht, ja.
Was weiß ich, mein Teil geschwungen vor der Kamera und dann hätte ich wieder ausgemacht.
Meint ihr, ich hätte auch nur einen 3 Tage Bann gekriegt?
Mal ernsthaft.
Meint ihr, ich hätte je wieder auf der Plattform streamen dürfen?
Zu Recht ehrlich gesagt.
Also, das wäre vollkommen zu Recht gewesen.
Probier mal.
Also, wenn ich einen Permabann gekriegt hätte, meiner Meinung nach vollkommen zu Recht.
Und wahrscheinlich hätte ich noch eine Anzeige gekriegt wegen irgendwelchen sexueller Belästigung.
Frag mich nicht, im Livestream oder so.
Keine Ahnung.
So, und da finde ich halt die Auslegung ein bisschen wenig nachvollziehbar,
dass es dann dort einen 3 Tage Bann gibt.
Und im Umkehrschluss, wenn einer im Stream gebaitet wird,
ein Bild aufzumachen, was halt fragwürdigen Content enthält.
30 Tage Bann.
Ja, oder weil einer oder eine in dem Fall die falschen Wörter verwundet hat.
7 Tage Bann.
Also, man muss halt mal sagen, das ist für mich dann nicht mehr nachvollziehbar.
Jemand auf der einen Seite sagen kann,
hey, ein ganz klarer Verstoß ohne jetzt irgendwie Auslegungssache gegen die Richtlinien, 3 Tage.
Und die falschen Wörter benutzt, wo man sich dann für einen entschieden hat,
die darf man nicht sagen, 7 Tage.
Also, ja.
Es ist, das ist ehrlich gesagt aber das Einzige, was mich auf Twitch stört,
dass die Auslegung der Richtlinien gefühlt irgendwie random ist.
Was natürlich jetzt für mich nicht so schlimm ist,
ich kann mit YouTube Geld verdienen, ich gehe arbeiten, ich verdiene so Geld,
aber überlegt euch mal, wenn du wirklich ein Fulltime Streamer bist
oder wenn du wirklich jemand bist, dessen Existenz daran hängt, Livestreams zu machen.
Und der hängt so in der Schwebe, der weiß nicht so genau, ob er das darf,
ob er das nicht darf, er kriegt keine genaue Aussage,
er sieht mal, wird es übelst geahndet, mal gar nicht, das ist schon kacke,
aber ansonsten muss ich sagen, ist Twitch die beste Livestreaming-Plattform, die es gibt.
Ja, und zum Mixer kann ja auch keiner mehr geben.
Alter, Mixer war von Anfang an so eine Stunde.
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum Microsoft da so viel Geld reingesteckt hat.
Die hätten mal mich fragen sollen und mich einfach für 5 Millionen konsulten sollen,
dann hätte ich ihnen gesagt, Leute, lasst Mixer bleiben, oder hätten sie viel Geld gespart.
Easy, easy money, und ich wäre reich gewesen, perfekt, so hätten wir das machen sollen, oder?
Experimentwärtswert, ja.
So Leute, ich habe jetzt nicht Chat gelesen, muss mal kurz, muss mal kurz schnell gucken.
Ähm, doch, haben sie, er hat es interessiert, aber auch kein so großartig.
Ähm, ich finde es, ich bin weder dafür noch dagegen, Captain Peng,
aber es sollte einheitlich sein, dafür bin ich.
Das werde ich dir nicht erzählen, aber wenn du danach suchst, findest du es auf jeden Fall.
Das war ein riesen Ding.
Ja, garantiert, deswegen ist ja, was meinst du, warum Explicit Sexual Content auf Twitch nicht erlaubt ist?
Natürlich gucken hier viele Minderjährige.
Äh, klar, sonst wäre ja alle streamt auf 18.
Deswegen finde ich es auch vollkommen gerechtfertigt, dass es nicht erlaubt ist.
Wing Wang, Prime Gaming, Dankeschön für den Sub, G-Styles, Dankeschön, 6 Monate, huge, IQ++, Subscriptions.
Ähm, muss ich noch was übersehen?
Hopp, hoffe ich mal nicht.
Nee, nee, nee, na Twitch erklärt ja auch nichts.
Wenn die was erklären würden, dann könnte man das auch nachvollziehen.
Aber ich glaube, die können das gar nicht erklären, weil ich, ich hab da ja keinen Einblick,
aber ich vermute mal, dass einfach unterschiedliche Auslegungen ist,
je nachdem wer diesen Band durchführt, das sind unterschiedliche Leute, die haben unterschiedliche Maßstäbe.
Und im Zweifelsfall wird halt auch geguckt, wer bringt mehr Geld?
Mein, letztendlich wollen die alle Geld verdienen.
Kann ich nicht mal irgendwie, bin ich ja nicht mal verwerflich.
Kennst du die YouTuber Bitbustler? Ja, von denen hab ich schon ein paar Videos geguckt.
Kannst du ein USB zu SATA Adapter empfehlen?
Ähm, ja, die kannst du eigentlich mehr oder weniger fast alles nehmen.
Äh, Leku auch gute Frage, ich wollte eigentlich was einkaufen, aber wir können jetzt erstmal eine Fragerunde machen.
Ähm, also zieh's in deine eigene Wohnung, Nvidia Shield Pro, das ist schon mal super, gibt kein besseres.
Außer, doch, doch, es gibt noch, es gibt noch was besseres, wenn du das über meinen RefLink gekauft hast.
So, und das nächste?
Ähm, äh, welche?
Gar keine, das ist nichts, womit ich, wo ich mich aktiv bei uns auf der Arbeit drum kümmere.
Ich weiß mit Ach und Krach grad mal, wie man den Kram bedient, keine Ahnung.
Ich bin ja nicht so der Terraform-Spezialist.
Was zum Kekken?
Ich trau mich nicht, das aufzumachen, Leute, im Chat immer.
Was ist das?
Das check ich nicht, Sebao, das ist mit, da bin ich zu low-prine für, das versteh ich nicht, den Witz.
Relaxed Critical Information.
Versteh ich nicht.
Ach so, ja die Logos stimmen nicht.
Wo, wo davon ist Nutella?
Ach so, die Logos stimmen hinten vorn, ja, okay.
Aber den Kontext kapier ich trotzdem nicht.
Ist das so ein Quiz gewesen, welches Logo gehört zu welchem Name?
Also das ist auf jeden Fall Vodafone.
Das ist Skype, das stimmt.
Aldi, Lego, ARD, weiß ich was das ist, Aral, ja, Kraft, Motorola, äh, stimmt Starbucks?
Nee, oder?
Sieht Starbucks so aus?
Ich geh nicht in Starbucks.
Ach, was weiß ich?
Siehst du mal, ich guck zu wenig Werbung um sowas, ich würde da auch voll abkacken.
Noch eine bessere Maus, kann man das aufmachen?
Oh, Hello Kitty Maus, exzellent.
Na, aber ich find die besser, die 1200 dpi USB, verdrahtete optische Gaming Spiel, Mäuse, Maus, tragbare niedliche KI, eine Fischcomputer, stille PC, Laptop Zubehör.
Das klingt doch exquisite.
Ja, kannst du, ich hab, ich hab nen 50er Pack, ich hab nen 50er Pack USB-Kabel gekauft.
Was ist deine Meinung zu Gnome?
Der Chat weiß das, Chat, jetzt, jetzt können wir mal, jetzt können wir mal.
Was ist meine Meinung zu Gnome, Chat?
Also, ernsthaft, optisch finde ich Gnome mittlerweile gar nicht übel.
Ich mag aber keinen Linungs-Desktop, um ehrlich zu sein.
Das einzige, was ich halbwegs verwenden kann ist i3, das ist ja kein Desktop, also du hast ja gar kein Desktop mit Icons und sowas.
I3 ist das einzige, mit dem ich gut klarkomme, der Rest fühlt sich sowohl, sowohl Gnome als auch KDE und auch zum Teil XFCE, fühlt sich alles wie unfertiger Kram an.
Äh, da kann ich auch Windows verwenden, wenn ich unfertigen Kram haben will.
Aber es ist Windows auf andere Art und Weise unfertig.
So, aber Chat, weiter im Text.
Ursprünglich wollte ich ja eigentlich was einkaufen.
Dann noch mal kurz durch den Chat scrollen euch da.
Äh, gibt es das Netzteil, was du für die Custom-LEDs genommen hast, auch günstiger, ohne dass es dir um die Ohren fliegt?
Finde nichts vergleichbares. Ich hatte einen 5 Volt, 10 Ampere Netzteil.
Warte mal.
Sowas, sowas hier in der Richtung, 26 Euro ist doch okay.
Kann man doch ausgeben, weil viel billiger müsst ihr das wahrscheinlich nicht kriegen.
Zumal das auch noch ein Hersteller ist, wo man halt davon ausgehen kann, dass es einem nicht um die Ohren fliegt.
Man muss dazu sagen, natürlich mit Prime-Versand, ohne Prime-Versand sackts.
Aber richtig Massive.
Wie gesagt, USB-Kabel kannst du auf AliExpress kaufen.
Ich hab auch mal vor einer Weile einen 50er-Pack.
Da sagt der Chat immer, Max, wozu braucht man einen 50er-Pack?
Aber ich hab mir auch schon einen 50er-Pack USB-Kabel gekauft bei Amazon.
Äh, nicht bei Amazon, bei AliExpress.
Nämlich einen USB, so einen 2-Meter-Kabel sind das.
USB auf USB-C mit Adapter auf Micro-USB.
Einfach aus dem Grund, dann hab ich genug.
Für, ja, lange Zeit.
Äh, was du dir noch holen sollst, ja, Neko, das kommt drauf an, was du Heimautomatisierungs machen willst. Was hältst du von Vodafone?
Jetzt hab ich im Chat aber endlich alles durch.
Alter, das hört ja gar nicht auf, ey.
Funktioniert da eine Heizungssteuerung noch? Das ist keine Heizungssteuerung, die wertet die Heizung nur aus.
Oder weißt du nicht, woran das liegen könnte mit Battlefield Venice Unleashed? Was, wie? Hä? Was, wie wo? Was liegen könnte?
Hast du dann fertige Smart Home Backend? Ich benutze das hier.
Das da verwende ich.
Das ist eine Software, mit der du ziemlich einfach alle möglichen Sachen zusammen verwalten kannst.
Du kannst C-Wave verwenden, Zigbee verwenden, WLAN-Geräte verwenden, Philips Hue verwenden.
Äh, alles, alles im Endeffekt, was es so gibt, ja.
Du kannst deine Micro-Controller integrieren, deine Raspberry-Pies, deine Lific-Sachen, dein Android, dein iPhone, du kannst alles möglich.
Mal hier gucken, Integrations, was die haben. Die haben 1727 Integrations mit den unterschiedlichsten Sachen.
Also das kann fast alles, das Ding.
POG-Champ wurde gebannt? Ja, aber es ist mittlerweile wieder da.
Wenn der Ton nicht geht...
Was habe ich mir jetzt neu? Das kenne ich nicht. Vielleicht das falsche Audio-Gerät ausgewählt oder so, keine Ahnung.
So.
Exzellent würde ich sagen, korrekt. Exzellent.
Also, okay, dann können wir erst mal was einkaufen. Und zwar, ihr habt ja im letzten Stream mitge- oder stimmt gar nicht, war gar nicht im letzten Stream, mit einem der letzten Streams.
Ich habe ja meinen Raspberry Pi 4, habe ich ja als Bastel-Ding hier im Einsatz gehabt.
Wir haben ja schon relativ viel im Stream damit auch ausprobiert.
Allerdings habe ich den jetzt für was verwendet, dass ich nicht mehr mit ihm basteln kann.
Und zwar, wenn ich dabei war, ich habe damit meinen alten Raspberry Pi 3 abgelöst, der...
Ey, der witzt mich auch schlecht auf Twitch. Was ist denn hier los gerade?
MonkaS!
Hier, taug dieses Raspberry Pi Gehäuse.
So, und hier...
...habe ich das ja...
Hier.
Die stehen ja umgebaut.
Max, zeig doch mal.
Das habe ich ja umgebaut in das Gehäuse mit einem SSD dran.
Und ich habe meinen alten Raspberry Pi 3 abgelöst, der hat ein bisschen wenig Speicher gehabt.
Das Ding macht UniFi-Controller für meine UniFi Access Points.
Und ist dafür für meine Überwachungskameras zuständig, die halt zu streamen.
Und der Raspberry Pi 3 hatte nur 1 GB RAM.
Und das war ein bisschen wenig, der ist out of memory gegangen.
So, und dann habe ich das umgezogen auf den 4er, der hat 4 GB Memory.
Und das ist jetzt alles wunderbar, es ist auch ein bisschen schneller und funktioniert ziemlich gut.
Das einzige Problem ist, die Software ist immer noch abgekackt mit out of memory.
Bis ich dann drauf gekommen bin, dass ich an irgendeiner Stelle einen Memory Leak fabriziert habe.
Und das musste ich erst mal rausfinden, woran es lag.
Wohlgemerk, einen Memory Leak ohne Memory zu leaken, hatte sowas einer schon mal?
So dumm es klingt, hatte jemand schon mal einen Memory Leak ohne Memory zu leaken?
Klingt jetzt erst mal widersprüchlich, aber das war es tatsächlich.
Und zwar, ich habe einen Overflow gehabt in einer Liste, die ist zu groß geworden.
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen hat es aber kein Memory Leaked, in dem Sinn, dass es immer mehr RAM gebraucht hat.
Wahrscheinlich, weil die Einträge in der Liste nahezu Null waren, wie die Größe davon.
Ich habe es geschafft, eine Liste überlaufen zu lassen.
Also zu viele Elemente in der Liste.
Und das habe ich geschafft, dadurch, dass ich jedes einzelne Bild von der Kamera gequeued habe.
Allerdings die Queue nie ausgelesen, also nie, also ich habe immer nur reingeschrieben und nie rausgelesen.
Weil ich gar nicht wusste, dass die überhaupt existiert an der Stelle.
So, und jetzt habe ich einfach das rausgeschmissen, jetzt funktioniert alles.
So.
Ja, dazu kommt es ja auch noch, dass der Object Detection macht, ob Leute durchs Bild laufen oder so.
Das hat 1 GB RAM einfach nicht gelangt.
Und jetzt habe ich meinen Raspberry 3 abgelöst durch diesen Vierer hier mit dem neuen Gehäuse und 4 GB RAM.
Dementsprechend brauche ich zum Basteln einen neuen.
Und jetzt bin ich gerade am überlegen, ob ich mir nicht einen 8 GB kaufen soll.
Es ist sinnlos.
Ich finde, man braucht eigentlich 8 GB nicht.
Aber warum nicht?
Welche Rev-Version ist das denn? Das ist Model B?
Die B heißen die immer, ne? Gute Frage, was das für einer ist.
Das ist bestimmt schon der Neue.
Das ist der ohne USB-Probleme, hoffe ich mal.
Das ist Desktop-PC-Performance.
Nein.
Das können die Raspberry Pi Jungs noch so oft schreiben.
Denn Raspberry Pi ist nicht Desktop-PC-Performance.
Guck mal, Berry Base, bei denen war ich noch nie.
Ich habe bisher nur mal Pimeroni und Pi Hat heißen, die UK bestellt.
Berry Base, exellent.
Pass auf, wir gucken jetzt mal Impressum, da steht bestimmt der Twinko jetzt dabei.
Glaub ich nicht. Würde mich auch nicht wundern.
Was haben die denn hier am Start? Kids? Was haben die für Kids?
Wobei die offiziellen Gehäuse sind halt Schrott.
Lohnt sich überhaupt nicht.
Die Pi 400 ist dieses unsinnige Keyboard, was keiner braucht.
Da weiß ich auch nicht, was die geritten hat.
Mit diesem Unsinn. Das ist total unsinnig. Ich verstehe die Existenzberechtigung davon nicht.
Gibt es jetzt ein offizielles Gehäuse? Wirklich?
Ach, nee.
Was ist das offizielle Gehäuse mit Lüfter?
Das ist ja mehr oder weniger das, was ich hatte.
Das ist ja mehr oder weniger fast schon das, was ich da an Weihnachten zusammengebaut habe.
Der Pi 4 hat integriertes WLAN, deshalb haben alle integriertes WLAN ab dem Raspberry Pi 3.
Der 1er und 2er hatte noch keins.
Das Pikmin Musik, das kann gut sein, dass das Pikmin Musik ist, ja.
Das ist Pikmin Musik.
Gibt es ein offizielles Gehäuse mit flüssigem Stickstoff?
Das bräuchte man noch.
Wann kommt der Pi 5 erstmal so schnell nicht, denke ich?
Zumal ich eh gespannt bin, was die beim Pi 5 machen wollen.
Die sind ja jetzt schon so mehr oder weniger am Limit.
Mal gucken.
Ja, was kostet es denn hier? Zeig mal her.
Boards.
Zero habe ich noch welche hier.
Und Jul B, 2G, 8G.
Ich bin echt am überlegen, ob ich mir einfach Just For Fun die 8G Variante kaufe.
Oh, das Sebaro hat wieder Big Brain Setup.
Kann ich den Link posten? Wohin denn?
Kommt drauf an, wohin der Link geht, ob du fliegst oder nicht.
Ach hier, ok.
Ich weiß ja nicht.
Das sieht mal äußerst behelfsmäßig aus, was die da gestrickt haben.
Gibt es das auch von oben? Wo saugt der denn überhaupt Luft an?
Wo saugt der bitte schön Luft an?
Verstehe ich nicht.
Hä?
Nee, durch die Ports kann er nichts ansaugen. In den Ports stecken die Stecker trennen vom Raspberry Pi dann.
Wo kriegt der Luft her?
Versteht das jemand? Ich kapiere es nicht.
Wir gucken uns das jetzt mal auf YouTube an.
Aber ich glaube, ich kaufe mir einfach wieder so ein komplettes Alugehäuse.
Belan Luft, das wird sein Chat.
Er erzeugt sich Luft, das ist quasi ein Luftspawner.
Ja, da haben wir jetzt Übung seit dem letzten Zusammenbauen mit.
Das können wir jetzt ja.
Ja, so weit hätte ich das auch noch hingekriegt.
Ok.
Das funktioniert doch nett.
Hast du eine gute Idee, wie ich durch zwei Räume Cutkabel bekomme? Unterputzen, auffüllen, beides eher mehr und schwer machbar.
Äh.
Na ja gut, wenn du es nicht auf der Wand und nicht durch die Wand und nicht in der Wand machen kannst, dann äh.
Dann bist du ja irgendwie erschöpft, oder?
Also was, äh, was wohl ganz gut gehen soll, habe ich aber selbst noch nicht ausprobiert, ist, wenn noch Telefonleitungen liegen,
also wenn du Glück hast, dass noch irgendwie so zwei Kupferadern da sind, vielleicht von einem alten Telefon oder so,
da gibt es ja diese Adapter, die Netzwerk über so zwei Adern machen, die machen dann wahrscheinlich VDSL oder irgendwie sowas drüber.
Ähm.
Also wenn du noch irgendwie zwei Adern hast, die unbenutzt sind, dann kannst du das damit machen, das kostet aber ein bisschen was.
Da brauchst du, ich hab mir das nur mal angeguckt vor einem Jahr, weil ich überlegt habe, ob ich sowas nicht von mir aus dem Keller in meinen Miniserver-Raum mache.
Und da hab ich nämlich auch nur noch zwei Adern übrig.
Das macht unter der Haube wahrscheinlich so eine Art VDSL dann.
Du hast auf der einen Seite ein Gerät, da steckst du deinen A45-Netzwerkstecker rein, dann klemmst du deine zwei Kupferadern auf der einen Seite an,
auf der anderen Seite, und da steckst du dann wieder das ähm.
Stimmt, richtig, PClustig hat recht, das hab ich auch gesehen, wenn es noch Kabel gibt von, achso, ja dann.
Also wie gesagt, es gibt diese, ich hab vergessen wie da wieder Kram heißt, äh, VDSL,
Kupfer oder Ethernet, Zweitrad, Konverter oder so Dinger, hatte ich mir vor einer Weile mal angeguckt.
Allnet kann sein, ich hab's dann aber nie gemacht, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich hab das nie gemacht, aber ich finde das Klang sympathischer als Powerline.
Also diese Dinger, also wie gesagt, damit hätte ich's wahrscheinlich gemacht, wenn ich das mit dem Keller gemacht hätte.
Powerline bin ich ja persönlich auch kein großartiger Fan von oder D-Lan und so, das ist ja alle mehr oder weniger das gleiche.
Also so hätte ich's wahrscheinlich probiert, wenn natürlich gar nichts da ist, dann fällt mir jetzt auch nichts ein.
Aber wenn du sagst, es ist DSL da oder vielleicht ja noch die ein oder andere unbenutzte Kupferleitung, vielleicht hast du Glück.
Ansonsten, ich weile halt im Zweifelsfall, wenn gar nichts geht, kann man sich ja immer noch einen kleinen,
einen Access Point im kleinen Modus dann lieber in den Rechner stellen, wenn man das Rechner per Kabel anschließen will.
Aber das ist halt echt auch nur die letzte Möglichkeit.
Wieso kein Fan von Powerline, weil ich schon viel zu oft gehört hab, dass es Probleme gibt.
Weiß was ich, wenn die Mikrowelle angeht, dass es nicht richtig funktioniert, dass es Störungen mit irgendwas verursacht,
dass es teilweise von einem Raum geht und der andere Raum dann wieder nicht.
Einfach in der Sockelleiste legen, oh das ist natürlich auch eine gute Idee.
Wenn du, wenn du, stimmt, stimmt, wenn du unten am Teppich so ein, wie auch immer das heißt.
Das ist auch eine coole Idee.
Wie gesagt, Powerline hab ich auch nicht vorgeschlagen.
Wie gesagt, das Einzige, was mir jetzt einfällt, ist dieses Netzwerk quasi verlängern über zwei Kupferdrähte.
So, warte mal, da gab es hier noch andere Questions.
Ich hab dich beim letzten Mal gefragt, welches OS du für dein NAS benutzen würdest. Deine Antwort war für normale Hardware Ubuntu.
Achso, ne, ne, ne, das mein ich. Das Server Hardware und normale Hardware ist für mich das gleiche.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr, in welchem Kontext ich das gesagt hab, aber wahrscheinlich wollte ich drauf raus,
falls du irgendwie einen Raspberry Pi verwenden willst oder irgendeinen Odroid oder sonst was,
dann würde ich das nehmen, was am besten die Hardware supportet, aber ansonsten würde ich Ubuntu Server nehmen.
Ich bin Ubuntu Server-Fan, ich hab damit keine Probleme, das zu sagen, ja.
Aber wir auf der Arbeit machen sich immer über Ubuntu lustig.
Und jetzt musste ich sie auslachen mit CentOS.
Hab ich gesagt, ja gut, wenigstens wird die Ubuntu noch ein bisschen supportet, aber das ist ein anderes Thema.
Die ganzen Red Hat Fanboys jetzt richtig, richtig reingeschissen haben sie.
Richtig reingeschissen, hätten sie gleich mal Ubuntu verwendet, alles wäre gut gewesen.
Oder Debian, Debian ist auch okay, ja.
Rocky OS kommt bald, ja, mal gucken.
Du weißt, wie schwierig das ist, Stonks Leuten einen Betriebssystemwechsel zu verkaufen, oder?
Die haben davon gar keine Ahnung.
Sagst du irgendeinem Stonks-Mensch, wir steigen jetzt um von CentOS auf Rocky Linux,
dann sagt der, hä, warum, wie, was, warum, warum Betriebssystemwechsel?
dann sagst du ihm, ja das ist genau das gleiche, dann sagt er, das glaube ich nicht, da hätten die sich ja nicht umbenannt
oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung
oder er macht sich drüber lustig oder was auch immer, also das ist es nicht so ohne
oh was ist denn jetzt los, auf einmal
was?
verschenkt 5 stufe 1 abos, danke schon für die ganzen subs
massive subscription
IQ++++++++++++ ist das jetzt ja quasi schon
6 head, wer hat etwas abgekriegt?
also wie gesagt danke für die 5 subs
ich kann sowas nicht aussprechen
ich würde auf den Raspberry Pi gar keinen nass laufen lassen, weil der Raspberry Pi denkbar schlechtbare Grundlage für nass ist
was ist dieses Raspberry Pi Compute Module?
das ist ein Raspberry Pi 4 mit einem bisschen größeren Board
da ist glaube ich auch ein PC Express Anschluss drauf
du bestellst das mal, da hat es ja schon was gebracht
danke für die ganzen subs
Twingo hat Subscribed, danke schön
ich habe glaube ich ein paar Sachen übersehen
ja Twingo danke für den Sub
aber hier oben sonst noch, ich hoffe ich habe nicht so viel übersehen
ich gucke noch mal kurz rein, weil immer wenn ich so in Schwätzen komme, kennt ihr mich ja
übersehe ich so Dinger
ich glaube
ich glaube jetzt habe ich alles gesehen
hast du Informatik studiert?
ne habe ich nicht
und jetzt bevor der nächste kommt, ja ich weiß, dass ich mit dem Casten schon ewig ein Video dazu machen wollte
also mit dem MasterCrupper Casten
das liegt nicht an mir, dass das nicht kommt
ich bin unschuldig, das liegt am Casten
der drückt sich da sonst seit 100 Jahren davor
ja
wie gesagt, ich würde gar kein Nass auf dem Raspberry Pi 4 laufen lassen
oder generell nicht auf, nein, nein
Leku, nein
ich würde gar kein Nass auf dem Raspberry Pi laufen lassen
Raspberry Pi ist kein allzu gutes Nasssystem
aktivierst du die Emotes von Hand?
die hier, die aktiviere ich von Hand, beste
guck so sieht das bei mir aus
ich habe auf dem anderen Monitor das hier offen
da kann ich einfach anklicken was ich haben will
ja zum Beispiel
wenn ich denke der Chat schläft ein
dann mache ich den hier
und jetzt, und jetzt machen sie alle so
und haben sich erschreckt
ok, machen wir mal weiter
also ich glaube, ich glaube, komm
ich brauche mir wirklich mal den
mit 8G
es ist zwar total sinnlos mit 8G
aber warum nicht, es geht
also mir fällt keine legit
also keine
ich kann mir nur ein paar Sachen zusammen
konstruieren, dass man 8GB braucht
auf dem Raspberry Pi
also so eine wirklich gute Anleitung für 8GB fällt mir nicht ein
die man nicht auch mit 4 machen kann
kann man sowas wie Chromecast mit einem Raspberry Pi hinbekommen?
ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung
ich meine, du kannst Android einfach installieren
auf dem Raspberry Pi
es gibt Soft, also wenn du
Musik irgendwie im Haus parallel gesyncht
abspielen willst
gibt es Möglichkeiten
wie es mit Video casten aus, ich habe keine Ahnung
habe ich mich noch nie mit beschäftigt
PogChamp wurde entfernt, ne da ist mittlerweile wieder da
das RZ Video, ahja
da habe ich noch nichts
muss ich, muss ich machen
hast du den TP Link
mit dem Omada Controller gesehen?
sieht fast aus wie Unify
ne, habe ich nicht gesehen
zeig mal
es sieht ein bisschen aus wie Unify
aber wie willst du so eine Oberfläche sonst machen?
aber wahrscheinlich sind die
Unify Access Points schlicht und ergreifend
immer noch deutlich besser
zum
Musik
kennst du einen guten Bausatz
für digitale Schilder?
ne
kauf dir den Raspberry Pi
in einem lokalen Raspberry Pi Store
ne, da muss ich ja unter Leute gehen
ne
das ist ja auch schon ein deutscher Shop
guck mal mal
3,4,8,g,b
ne, das günstigste ist 77
da kann ich den auch kaufen
also 8G, ich kaufe mit dem mit 8G
ich habe genug Prime Subs gekriegt
kann ich mir das jetzt auch leisten
wie ist eure Meinung
zur Netzwerkzeug von Mikrotik
aber ich bin Mikrotik Fanboy
jetzt ernsthaft
ich wollte gar keinen Lul machen
ich wollte Dings machen hier, Pok
den man nicht mehr machen darf, ich mag Mikrotik
ich finde Mikrotik ist
massiv nice, für den Preis auf jeden Fall
jetzt 38 Berries sichern
ne, ich will nur einen
das reicht mir
also, gut
da brauche ich noch einen Case dazu
Netzteile
ach, Moment
ja gut, wenn wir schon dabei sind
wenn wir schon dabei sind
da kann ich das Netzteil ja auch noch dabei nehmen
aus so einem Crap braucht man nicht
7 Euro noch
wie kommt der jetzt auf
wie kommt der jetzt auf 100
hä
hä, was ist das Quickmuffs
ich habe alles abge- ach ne
da ist die Tastatur und so noch dabei
die kann man nicht abhaken
so ein Schwachsinn
hä, da nicht
aber das Netzteil würde ich tatsächlich
mit bestellen
einfach weil es schön klein, kompakt ist
und schon USB-C Stecker dran hat
ich weiß, braucht keine
Ankorb, zack
84 Euro Exquisite
so, haben die ein schönes Case hier
irgendwas, das muss, sonst kann ich auch bei
Amazon bestellen
die, die, die, die Gehäuse sind cool
aber die sind mir zu teuer
das da, das Flick
oh
hätte ich es mir sofort bestellt
was kostet denn bei Amazon
Pi, 4, 8, GB
bei denen
Pi, 4, kost 8G
73 Pfund
was sind 73
sind es glaube ich, ne
2 Euro
ok, lohnt sich das
dann, dann bestelle ich das da
und das Gehäuse bestelle ich einfach bei Amazon, easy
ganz einfach
hab vor ein paar Tagen
ach stimmt
ne Moment, wie sieht es jetzt aus
nach dem Brexit, gibt es jetzt Zoll
oder gibt es kein Zoll
ich hab keine Ahnung
hab vor ein paar Tagen angefangen Lilux zu lernen
und hab mir das Ziel gesetzt
dieses Jahr ein Red Hat Zertifikat
zu machen, was hältst du davon
meinst du es ist eine gute Sache, in der man technisch
das kommt drauf an, was willst du denn
für ein Red Hat Zertifikat machen
ich hab jetzt nicht im Kopf was Red Hat für Zertifikate machen
das erste was mir einfällt
linux-mäßig ist so der Standard Lpick
das hat jetzt mit Red Hat nichts zu tun
was willst du für ein Red Hat Zertifikat machen
also es kommt
ein bisschen drauf an
es kommt ein bisschen drauf an
also gerade in Deutschland gibt es sicherlich
die einen oder anderen Firmen, die da drauf gucken
gerade so die oldschool
Stonks-Dinger
also mich würde nicht wundern, wenn bei uns
in der Bank auch Leute auf Zertifikate gucken
aber ich persönlich bin der Meinung
dass Zertifikate jetzt
ja also
es schützt einen nicht
davor Ahnung zu haben
sag mal so
also reine Zertifikat
bringt nichts
also ich könnte mir schon vorstellen, dass es was bringt
wenn die wirklich jemand suchende Erfahrung
mit Red Hat hat, wenn das wirklich
explizit drin steht, wir suchen jemand
tiefergehende
Erfahrungen oder irgendwie
fortgeschrittene Erfahrungen mit Red Hat
und du hast dann ein Red Hat Zertifikat
dann könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass das schon einen ganz guten Eindruck macht
das allein wird dir den Job aber wahrscheinlich
nicht bringen
je nachdem was es kostet
und für einen zeitlichen Aufwand ist
ist es sicherlich nicht verkehrt
aber ich kann dir das wirklich leider keinen
allzu guten Ratschlag zu geben
ach ja und das stimmt nicht
das stimmt nicht
mit dem Zoll, was ist das für ein
Charity Event, das mit dem Zoll aus China
stimmt nicht so richtig
ja es ändert sich diese
Freigrenze, unter dem du keinen Zoll
bezahlen musstest, aber
das ist erstens jetzt schon egal
also weil
die China Dudes ja eh nur
Mist drauf schreiben im Endeffekt
und jetzt auch das meiste gar nicht
darunter fällt, dass es verzollt werden muss
weil es gibt zwei Varianten
wie die China Leute, das vollkommen
legal
wie lange geht der Lockdown noch, wo soll ich das denn
wissen
machst du mal auf twitter ad Regierungsprecher
und frag nicht mich
wo soll ich das wissen
genau
also zu diesem China Zeug kann man sagen
wenn man bei AliExpress oder wenn man bei
Banggood bestellt, wir waren ja schon lange nicht mehr auf
Banggood
und wenn man hier was bestellt
ich habe jetzt hier irgendwie einen 3D Drucker auf
und
der ist grad nicht da, ich muss mir irgendwas aussuchen
was da ist
zum Beispiel hier diese Kopfleuchte
wollte ich schon immer mal bestellen
exakt diese Kopfleuchte brauche ich
so und wenn man
dann hier auswählen kann
EU Priority Line
dann machen die nämlich folgendes
es gibt zwei vollkommen
legale Möglichkeiten für diese China
Versender, die die Zollsachen
in Deutschland zu umgehen
oder generell in Europa zu umgehen
das erste ist
die verschicken einfach
die Waren nicht aus
China, sondern
die haben einen Warenlager in der EU
und verschicken es von da
und immer mehr Shops haben
einen Warenlager in der EU
weil immer mehr Leute aus Europa bestellen
in China, da ist es natürlich auch
für alle Seiten gut, wenn man die Waren
vor Ort lagert, zumindest die oft bestellt werden
und nicht jedes mal mit Schiff hinfahren muss
das ist für die Leute gut, weil die mehr bestellen
wann schneller da ist und für den Laden auch gut
weil es logistisch einfacher ist
das ist das erste
die verschicken ist aus dem EU Warenlager
dann gibt es zollmäßig gar keine Probleme
weil du innerhalb der EU
verschicken kannst, das ist kein Problem
es geht ja nur, bei der ganzen Sache geht es ja nur drum
wenn du Sachen aus
China quasi mehr oder weniger
direkt nach Deutschland schickst
das nächste ist
was Aliexpress auch schon ganz lange macht
die schicken die Sachen einfach nicht nach Deutschland
sondern über die Niederlande
da kommt dann wahrscheinlich
ein Schiff in Rotterdam an und dann geht es
mit der niederländischen Post weiter
so und was spätestens
jetzt viele Shops in China machen werden
und was schon immer gemacht wurde
wenn du EU Priority Line
ausgewählt hast ist
die schicken das gar nicht
direkt aus China zu dir
sondern die schicken das
erst mal zu einer
Zwischenstation zum Beispiel nach Spanien
und in Spanien
schicken sie es weiter zu dir
und nachdem
das quasi von Spanien
innerhalb der EU an dich geschickt wird
musst du eh keinen Zoll drauf bezahlen
das heißt die Chinesen werden das nach wie vor
easy haben, dass du
keinen Zoll bezahlen musst
wohlgemerkt
das ist noch nicht mal was
Anrüchiges oder so, das ist vollkommen
egal, das ist
in Ordnung, ja
das könnten theoretisch auch alle anderen Händler so machen
ich meine du brauchst ein bisschen größeren
logistischen Aufwand für das es geht
wer es halt überhaupt gar nicht
geschissen bekommt, sind Händler
aus den USA
Händler aus den USA sind prinzipiell unfähig
das nach Europa zu schicken
und so zu kennzeichen, dass es für den Kunde
kein riesen Akt ist
sich mit dem Zoll auseinanderzusetzen
also die aus den USA, die kriegen es gar nicht gebacken
alles was ich bisher aus den USA
bestellt hatte, ist beim Zoll gelandet
ohne Mist, alles, ich habe jetzt nicht ultra viel
Sachen bestellt aus den USA, aber ich würde mal sagen
so mein Daumen, du bist daumengepeilt
zu ca. 13, 14, 15
Sachen oder so
oftmals halt auch
im Bundle
also Sendungen vielleicht
lass mal 5 sein oder so
5 Stück, und am schlimmsten war es
als ich mein
Ambilight Ding bestellt habe
für ein Fernseh, diesen Dreamscreen
die haben es überhaupt nicht hinbekommen
das war als sonst was
oder gar nicht deklariert
und da musste ich, ich zeige euch mal was das
Dreamscreen, das sind so
LED Streifen
die kann man hinten an Fernsehen machen
und
dann
leuchtet das eben
ob ich eben das Zelt da gesehen
dann leuchtet der Fernseh halt wie
der Inhalt, ne
ist eigentlich äußerst cool das Ding
und das habe ich bestellt aus den USA
ich war in Hanau beim Zoll
nicht in Frankfurt
aber das ist auch ein Bahnhof
und das habe ich aus den USA
bestellt, da musste ich den Zoll abholen gehen
und die haben es halt komplett verkackt
und da musste ich dem Zollmann erst mal
erklären, dass ich kein Fernseh bestellt habe
sondern Lichter, die man hinten
an den Fernseh dran klebt
weil das war über einen gewissen Betrag
und wenn du über einen gewissen Betrag bist, da musst du
ja quasi FAT
und Gedöns, ne nicht FAT, quasi
ein Fuhr, Gedöns bezahlen
Mehrwertsteuer bezahlen und
Zoll bezahlen
da musst du ja drei Sachen
irgendwie bezahlen und
je nachdem wieviel du Zoll
bezahlen musst, liegt daran
was du da in der
Box drinnen hast, was du bestellt hast
und der Zollmensch oder der Zollmann
der meinte halt
das wäre ein Fernseh, ich meine das war so eine kleine
Box, so, so, mit Verpackung drum herum
da musste ich ihm erstmal erklären,
Alter, guck mal das ist kein Fernseh, ich habe es ja
auch ausgepackt und habe ihm das gesagt
guck doch, sieht das aus wie ein Fernseh
das ist
das sind Lichter, die man an
Fernseh pappt und
da hat er glaube ich irgendeinen Beleuchtungskram
rausgesucht und dann ging das, es war echt
ätzend und die hatten absolut
keinen Bock auf den Zoll, sich mit den Leuten
auseinanderzusetzen
ganz ätzend, also Zoll
muss nicht sein
ne, echt nicht
naja zumindest das Produkt ist cool, gibt es leider nicht
mehr, so und das ist das
wo ich dann gesagt habe ey, ich bestelle
lieber alles nur
noch in China als in USA
ja
so sieht es aus, ja
so viel zum Thema Versenden
aus China nach Deutschland
Sorry für langen Text, was hast du
denn, achso
Aha
ich hab kein, okay also
sprich, ab 1. Januar
muss man Zoll bezahlen aus UK
oder was
Hehehe
Ich hab keine Ahnung, ich bestelle
aus UK aber eh nix mehr
weil der Wechselkurs
Pfund zu Euro nicht so gut ist
ich hab 2008, 2009
immer rum bestellt
hab ich immer Spiele bei Amazon bestellt
hat das vielleicht auch jemand von euch gemacht
zweite coole Zeit, da hast du aktuelle
Xbox Spiele anstatt für 60 Euro
für 35 Euro gekriegt in UK
das war echt nice
Damals
hab ich immer bestellt für 30 Euro
ja
das hat es richtig gelohnt
okay also
Raspberry Pi bestelle ich hier
alles klar, da brauch ich jetzt noch bei Amazon
das passende Gehäuse
haben die hier noch
was davon, ne das gibt es nicht mehr
dabei ist das richtig cool
das will ich haben
New
Welektron
zwölfter
aber dafür 7 Euro mehr
die Musik ist äußerst entspannend
wisst ihr was, scheiß drauf
da warte ich halt ein bisschen, ist mir auch egal
Hauptsache ich hab mal ordentliches Pi Case
das brauch ich nicht mehr
ja
gut wunderbar
haben wir das
ha Sirius Max
was ist mit Offenbach
in Offenbach gehts abends immer rund
was ist hier
hol dir das Gehäuse
ne
das gefällt mir gar nicht
wenn schon hole ich mir das gleiche
was ich an Weihnachten zusammengebaut hab
an Weihnachten hatte ich
ich hab
weiß gar nicht mehr, was ich an Weihnachten zusammengebaut hab
wie das hieß, das hier
das da
hab ich das hier irgendwo gezeigt, wie das hieß
IC Box
irgendwas von IC Box
Pi 4
das ist alles
wo ist das Gehäuse
mein Gehäuse gibt es auch nicht mehr
what the fuck, alles weg ey
dein Pi wird jetzt nicht
wärmer als 48 Grad unter Volllast
ja aber da hast du auch einen Kühler dran
weil ansonsten wird der
4er eindeutig wärmer unter Volllast
was gibt es eine
gibt es eine Möglichkeit vor
in ein
Konz
hä
was, verstehe ich nicht
das ist eine Schleife, die dynamisch was macht
das widerspricht doch Konz schonmal
oder wie, oder was, oder hä
verstehe ich nicht
es gibt bei Venice Unleashed
ja es gibt einen Rush Server, hab ich auch gesehen
wie immer
gleich nochmal eine Runde
die Ausgabe davon
äh
hä
welche Ausgabe
du meinst wenn du jetzt
irgendwie den Print machst auf I
ja das kannst du, in C++
kannst du das mit Sicherheit einfach einem Konz
zuweisen dann
was weiß ich, C++
Alter frag mich doch nicht so, Dinger
du kannst
bei C++ nur mit einer Sache
rechnen, dass es unlogisch ist
ach so wegen dem Messer im Warenkorb
ja das ist
in Deutschland gar nicht so
einfach
da gibt es tatsächlich Regeln was man haben darf
ich glaube dieses Teppichmesser was ich da hatte
das darf man besitzen
ich bestell das meiste bei Amazon
oder bei AliExpress oder bei Banggood
aber das meiste bei Amazon
äh Sebaro
ihr fragt mich immer Sachen
woher soll ich das denn wissen, ich hab das selbst noch nie ausprobiert
absolut keine Ahnung
zumindest braucht das
Single Core Performance
das heißt das hier dürfte ja Single Core
gar nicht so schlecht sein
aber du brauchst auf jeden Fall Single Core Performance
miete dir doch einfach irgendwo ein
so ähm also
Raspberry Pi
sag mal gibt es eigentlich noch Xbox 360
Controller zu kaufen
das mit dem Mikrofon auf einem Schreibtisch
macht mich immer noch so fertig
was ich euch am Anfang des Streams erzählt hab
das macht mich immer noch so fertig, dass ich das Mikrofon jetzt
vom Schreibtisch runtergestellt hab
dass ich es nicht mehr sehen muss, weil mich das jedes Mal dran erinnert
dass ich es nicht gesehen hab
gibt es eigentlich einen Xbox 360 Controller zu kaufen?
ne alles nur Fake
alles nur Fake
das ist kein Originaler
das sind alles keine Originalen Controller
Gizimiti
Daose
das klingt wie so ein aloe vera
Knichtsaufstrich oder sowas
aber nicht nach dem Xbox Controller
ich hab nochmal Original
Original
Jumpswall
alles klar, komplett Original
was für ein Mikrofon, ne ich kanns ja nochmal erzählen
weil am Anfang des Streams nicht alle da waren
ich hab doch
vor ein paar Wochen erzählt
dass ich mein Blue Yeti suche
dieses olle Ding da
und ich hab das
2-3 Wochen lang gesucht
dieses Mikrofon
also immer mal wieder
ich hab in den Schrank geguckt
hinter den Rechner überall
ich habe es ums verrecken nicht gefunden
es war einfach weg
einfach weg
und dann hab ich gestern
als ich das letzte Video aufgenommen hab
auch nochmal kurz hier rum geguckt, aber es ist nicht da
es war einfach weg, ich hab es nicht gefunden
und heute steh ich am Fenster
und guck nach rechts
auf mein Schreibtisch und da stehts
und so wie das aussieht
stand das schon immer da
ich hab es nicht gesehen
ich hab durchgeguckt
ich hab da einfach durchgeguckt
und das muss da immer gestanden haben
weil dort ist auch so ein richtig schöner
weißer
staub- und krümelfreier Ring
auf dem Schreibtisch
und da ist gar nichts einfach
das kommt mit dem Alter
ja wahrscheinlich
hier
da war der originale xbox controller
was wo
wo ist er
das was der sebao hier gefunden hat
naja
ja aber das gibt es ja nicht
in neu
der kabel gebunden ist mir sogar lieber
aber
die gibt es nicht neu ne
alles used
seid ihr doch
ja
der neue ist besser
als der 360 ne finde ich nicht
also der neue ist doch
1 zu 1 der xbox one controller
oder
heißt das ding jetzt x oder s
wie heißt denn der kack jetzt mittlerweile
xbox series
s xbox
series x ganz ehrlich microsoft
benamung die benamung ist so
unendlich scheiße
ich muss es jetzt einfach mal sagen wie es ist
die xbox
benamung ist unterirdisch
die letzte kacke
da blickt keine saume
durch nicht mal microsoft selbst
der da
das ist doch das ist doch das ist doch quasi
der xbox one controller oder
gibt es einen unterschied
außer das d pad
habe ihn gefunden
oh nice bei aliexpress
aliexpress beste
man sieht ja auch hier oben schon
eindeutig
der original xbox controller
genauso sah der aus ja
wer sich nicht mehr erinnern kann genau
genauso sah der oben wieder
bitte aus
ok also
im prinzip
also im prinzip wenn ich das richtig
verstehe chat ist der xbox
series x controller mehr oder weniger der xbox
one controller mit ein bisschen
d pad und mehr
kripp auf der
rückseite
gut das ist nämlich der grund warum
ich keinen xbox one controller will weil mir
die sticks zu klein sind
das ist das ich weiß es ist so eine pure
gewöhnheit sache und ich suche ja
einen gamepad für einen pc
also mal wieder nachdem das letzte jetzt langsam
aber sicher ganz schön ausgeleitet ist
und ich finde
die sticks vom xbox 360
controller viel angenehmer
als die sticks vom xbox one controller
ich kann das auch schlecht erklären
oh moment
die haben die anordnung
wieder anders gemacht
die anordnung ist jetzt wieder so wie früher
weil der xbox
der xbox one controller
der hatte die, nee hatte der die auch so
warte mal ich hab doch hier irgendwo ein liegen
achja ok die war schon
die waren schon immer so
ich dachte das hatten sie geändert
vom xbox one controller
aber da sieht man wie oft ich den in der
hand hatte
ich hab aktuell noch einen 360 controller
der ist beste
den allerersten xbox controller
den kenn ich der ist riesengroß
wie findest du den controller von der
allerersten xbox, fett
ja der playstation controller
den mag ich nicht
der s5 controller
hat sich da eigentlich
etwas getan jetzt
ja
man kann ihn wenigstens jetzt halbwegs ordentlich
in der hand halten nicht so wie bei der playstation 3
aber ist echt nicht meins
also
xbox 360 controller
for life ich sag's euch beste
ich will keine
längeren hebel ich will breitere
sticks der 360 controller
hat breitere sticks
und also vor allem nicht also breitere
breitere
breitere daumendinger oben
hi max wie hieß der
battlefield reiser von deinem letzten youtube video
der hieß
kann ich dir zeigen
kurz
er kennt
wir spielen jetzt
kein battlefield
hab ich jetzt gar keinen
aber ich mach mal login
server
nein er ist nicht dabei
warum heißt du dir whoop los
weil ne ne ne max fps ist nicht
tank max fps hab ich mir sogar reserviert
weil ich mir den account
angelegt hab bevor ich selbst gestreamt hab
und ich hatte gar nicht vor selbst zu streamen
und ja
irgendwann hab ich schon angefangen
zu streamen und hab ich so
gelassen und find's eigentlich auch gar nicht schlecht
das war der beste
controller
das war
der beste
gefällt mir am besten
scheitens nicht mehr zu geben
nur irgendwelche komischen nachbauten
das brauch ich jetzt auch net
so also
gehäuse haben wir bestellt, Raspberry Pi haben wir bestellt
das Raspberry Pi Netzteil haben wir bestellt
dann brauch ich noch einsatz ip 66
box
das sind die die ich für die LED-Leisten verwendet hab
die hier
da bestell ich mal nochmal ein paar von
die waren nämlich
äußerst praktisch
für irgendwelche kleinen Projekte
top
jetzt meine ganzen LED
Sachen und alles andere Zeug kommt jetzt
in so kleinen Boxen
alle mal besser als 3D gedruckter Crap
das Problem beim 3D
gedruckten Zeug ist
dass es nicht richtig wasserdicht
ne ne
insomniac tut ich bestell mal ein
das ist eine sehr gute Frage
ähm
weder noch
ist das ein Monte Streamer
ich find die verwechseln
zu verwechseln ähnlich oder
das ist eine gute Frage also
weder noch das beste ist eine SSD
Mikro SD Karte und USB Stick
nimmt sich nicht viel, weil der
Speicher in USB Sticks meistens der
allerletzte Crap ist und
ihr jeden Moment abkacken kann
also USB Sticks sind qualitativ
absolute Katastrophe
ich würd sogar sagen nimm ne Mikro SD Karte
und dann
nimmst du wenn du ne wirklich gute haben willst
nimmst du
Samsung Endurance
Mikro SD Karte
nimmst du die hier
die halten ordentlich
die sind auch gut
kosten auch ein bisschen mehr aber wirklich nice
das beste was du aber machen kannst ist
nimm ne SSD
was ist denn die günstigste
was ist denn so die günstigste SSD die es gibt
64G ich hab ehrlich gesagt
gar keine Ahnung ja hier guck mal
nimm ne SSD ohne Scheiß
die paar Euro mehr
kannst du ausgeben
und kriegst
was deutlich besseres
was sind die günstigste SSD hier
was Kingston
ah 400
hatte ich noch nie aber
kost nur
20 Euro
ja oh Mist dann nimm so was
also wenn du den Platz
hast dann nimm
ne SSD
brauchst du nicht unbedingt
ne billigere Mikro SD Karte
tut es auch aber wenn man
auf der sicheren Seite sein will dass das Ding
dir nicht eines Tages einfach nicht mal
bootet dann nimm ne SSD
ja es geht ja nicht ne ne ne Moment
Moment hier chat es geht ja nicht um
die Geschwindigkeit
die Geschwindigkeit ist das eine
der SSD ist auf jeden Fall immer noch
besser als ne Mikro SD Karte was das angeht
es geht darum dass das viel haltbarer ist
als der 0 auf 15 USB
Sticker oder Mikro SD Karte
ja 1948 kauf dir ne SSD
also wenn du den Platz dafür
hast und ich hab's ja hier im Stream auch gemacht
guck mal guck mal wie cool wir das gebaut
haben im Stream am Ende
passt mal auf
guck mal
die Vorschau hier unten stimmt auch nicht
die Vorschau hier unten ist auch wirklich
geil oder?
ja Moment hier liegt die
SSD noch nebendran
zeig's euch wir haben
es richtig wir haben das richtig cool gemacht
am Ende
mein Gott Twitch please
jebaitet uns doch nicht so
kann doch man irgendwie
spulen
hier guck mal so haben wir es am Ende
gemacht
ich würde gern Pause machen ohne
dieses Ding aber ok
so haben wir es am Ende
so haben wir es am Ende gemacht
also sprich die SSD
unter
das Gehäuse gepappt
drangeklebt ja
ich bin mir gar nicht sicher
hier liegt sie noch nebendran
kleben wir sie irgendwo dran
ah jetzt guck mal hier
Massive Klebsor mache ich ja jetzt
es bleibt 20 Grad kühler
alles klar
gut Max das haben wir jetzt verstanden
was du gerade
zeige wie wir die SSD
an unseren Raspberry Pi dran gepappt haben im letzten Stream
richtig satisfying dass es genau passt
ja aber richtig
hier hab ich geguckt auf jetzt kommen die Klebepads
dran
guck jetzt kommen die Klebepads
du kannst
den Pi von der SSD booten ja
es gibt keinen Pause Jam
mehr aber Leute ich hab Pause Jam wieder
hinzugefügt über Bella Twitch TV
Pause Jam
das kann eigentlich bald wieder gehen
geht schon
exzellent
guck so
dran gepappt und jetzt
zack
guck mal wie gut das passt
SSD genauso groß wie das Gehäuse
und das Ding hab ich jetzt unten stehen
und das macht halt mein Unify Controller
und Streaming für die Überwachungskameras
passt richtig gut
also wenn du genug Platz hast
und dich das nicht stört dass deine SSD unten drunter klebt
ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr wer es gefragt hat
mach eine SSD drunter
du kannst es ja ordentlich
festkleben nicht so komisch wie ich mit
Heatpipepads
sondern einfach was ordentliches
dazwischen pappen
und nicht dieses komische
Zeug was ich dazwischen geklebt hab
wenn du richtig cool bist nimmst du irgendwie so einen Velcro
oder sowas und dann kannst du es sogar wieder abmachen
ja richtig satisfying
wie das da unten drunter passt
und da kann sich jetzt ja wirklich
keiner beschweren dass das irgendwie
so nach Technik
gerade Mädels sind da ja immer so
die mögen das ja nicht so nach dem
oh nein da steht eine Fritzbox in der Ecke
das sieht ja total hässlich aus
eine Fritzbox, gut also wenn die schon eine Fritzbox
in der Ecke hässlich findet
dann mag die sicherlich auch keinen Raspberry Pi
der ohne Gehäuse in der Ecke steht
aber so
ist da sogar der
der Woman Acceptance Faktor
gegeben
finde ich das Gehäuse sieht nice aus
die SSD hängt nicht irgendwie rum
sieht nice aus, sieht einfach so aus wie es sein muss
ja
also so würde ich das jetzt machen
das Problem hast du nicht
ja dann hau die SSD unten dran
gibt es Pi Cases
mit interner Haltung
ja es gibt dieses
Argon
Pi
Case
mit M2
glaube das
das gibt es
aber
ist halt die Frage
ob es das lohnt
weil das Gehäuse ist halt deutlich
macht es halt deutlich fetter
da hat man eine SSD unten drunter gehängt
und man muss ja auch sagen M2
ist schon ein bisschen verschenkt
verschenkt beim Raspberry Pi jetzt
man kann es natürlich machen
wenn man will, dass das
rein kommt
ins Gehäuse aber ganz ehrlich
ich würde es so machen wie ich das gebaut habe
einen Fleer Case oder dieses IC Box Case
und dann unten drunter die
SSD geklebt, gut ist
Noob Frage, für was braucht man
den Raspberry Pi?
das ist gar keine allzu große Noob Frage
in der Regel ist es eher so
wenn du was machen willst, wo du ihn brauchst
dann weißt du, dass du ihn brauchst
so einfach mal random einkaufen
ja muss nicht sein
wichtig ist
bei dem Case nur SATA M2
naja, gut
was soll es ja auch sonst sein
das Ding hat ja kein PCE Express
und auch über USB nicht
im Prinzip ist das ja alles USB
Sebaro, du kannst ja mal nachgucken
die haben bestimmt auch schöne Handteigkissen
wenn du gerade da bist
Gag wait
so
was brauche ich denn sonst noch?
brauche ich sonst noch irgendwas interessantes
an das den Xbox 360 Controller
habe ich denn gewonnen
gut, ich brauche Katzenfutter, ich glaube das muss ich nicht im Stream kaufen
wisst ihr wo meine Katze
übelst drauf abgeht?
da drauf
Chicken and, Moment, nicht das
Chicken und Ente
ist das glaube ich
was, Lamm?
Duck?
zumindest auf diese Sorte Futter
da stehen die drauf
wieso bestellst du bei Amazon, weil es am einfachsten
und am bequemsten ist
teurer als Kaffee, ja das stimmt
aber das sind auch glaube ich 2 Kilo oder so
wie viel sind es?
ne 7, nicht 2 Kilo, 7,5 Kilo
da steht die richtig drauf
hast du das mitbekommen?
Moment
was?
ich weiß überhaupt nicht um was es da geht
Strom?
oder was?
Stromnetz?
kann das jetzt gerade überhaupt nicht zuordnen
7,5 Kilo Katze
das Stromnetz hat heute gewackelt
nichts von gemerkt
ich weiß nur, dass bei uns auf der Arbeit
das Stromnetz wackelt, weil sie irgendwelche
USV Tests machen demnächst
aber es macht ja nichts, ich bin ja im Homeoffice
da kann das so viel wackeln vor Ort
wie sie wollen
ja also da muss ich mir auf jeden Fall
aber ich will nicht die 7,5 Packung
ich brauch die kleinere
es gibt auch noch eine kleinere
wobei, eigentlich könnte ich auch die 7,5
die 7,5 Kilo nehmen
weil meine Katze frisst das eh
exellent
komm scheiß drauf
bam
aber
ohne Mist, das Zeug ist echt gut
meine Katze geht total drauf ab
und wisst ihr wo meine Katze auch übelst drauf ab geht
aber das Zeug ist nicht gut
das da
da geht die auch richtig drauf ab
also das, da kann ich
wenn ich mich da an die Tür stelle
und damit raschel, egal wo die ist
die ist innerhalb von 2 Sekunden da
du hörst da nur noch irgendwo
aus der Wohnung
angerauscht kommen
Treppe halb runter gehen
und dann
Treppe halb runter
gefallen, zack wieder am Start
also wenn ich damit raschle
ist vorbei
was ich alles im Warenkorb hab
Katzenfutter, das Raspberry Pi Gehäuse und 5
wasserdichte Cases
wenn das Stromnetz
die Frequenz nicht stimmt, dann gehen ja auch
von vielen Geräten falsch
die Katze dreht da auch her, ne?
Wiskars Knusper, beste
für die Katz, allerdings ist das mit Sicherheit nicht
gesund
und Nassfutter, was die mit Abstand
am liebsten frisst, meine Katz
ist der größte Dreck überhaupt
Gummi Gold
das da, das ist so richtig
das alle billigste
vom billigsten was es gibt
aber das find se geil
Rind und Huhn mag se
Eiersoufflé mit Huhn mochte die
alte, aber aktuell
Chico mag mit Rind und Huhn, ja
da geht die sowas von drauf ab
Purina ist Nestle, ich weiß es nicht
keine Ahnung
ist Purina
Nestle?
tatsächlich, ja
das ist, die hat da wirklich keine Ansprüche
ich hab früher, ich hab früher
für die, für die, für die, für die allererste
die ich hier hatte, hab ich immer hier
was ist das noch?
hab ich immer hier bestellt, die haben so
so Ausprobiersets gehabt
keine Ahnung ob die das immer noch haben
also
die hatten immer so
Sets, so 50 verschiedene
Sorten
hochwertiges Futter
und da hab ich immer für meine alte Katz was bestellt
und die fand das richtig geil, die mochte nämlich Abwechslung
Chico hasst Abwechslung
das muss der größte Dreck sein
weil das das einzige ist was ihr schmeckt und dann immer das gleiche
Gourmet, Gold
klingt nicht billig
ja das ist typisch Katzenfutter
es heißt
es heißt bei Katzenfutter prinzipiell
egal, egal
Zooplus hab ich auch schon Zeug bestellt
egal wie schlecht ist es immer Gold
Plus Premium
Gourmet und sowas
also bei Katzenfutter überschlagen sie sich komplett
ich hab ein Video aufgenommen von der Katz heute
mal gucken ob ich euch das zeigen kann
ok Chat
Chat ich blend euch mal kurz aus
dass ich mein Handy anschließen kann
wo hab ich denn mein
gibt es hier eine gute Variante
ohne USB
Videos vom Handy
also irgendwie per Wlan
Dateiübertragung vom iPhone
oder so
gibt es da irgendwas schönes für wenn man nicht gerade
einen Mac hat
Airdrop
Dropbox Nextcloud Sync
ja ich wollte es eigentlich direkt rüber ziehen
so warte mal ich zeig es euch mal
sortieren nach
ja
Datum
ach der erste
off
ich glaub das ist es
es ist auch mega langsam
über USB vom iPhone was abzuspielen
mach hinne
iPhone please
come on bra
lass mich nicht hängen
ich will jetzt die Leute nicht 3 Stunden warten lassen
Alter warum spielt der Crap denn nicht
der kopiert auch nicht
der kopiert auch gar nicht
was ist das für ein Crap wieder
da guckt euch das mal an
10 minutes
ok jetzt hat das gleich
ich hoffe das ist das richtige Video
aber das ist
feine Katze
ich muss euch jetzt halt noch mal ausmachen
weil ich gucken muss da ich nichts leake
hehehehe
genau
ok
so guckt mal hier
guckt mal hier
guckt mal
in der feine Katze
also ich hab drei Videos
ich wollte heute die Treppe
hochgehen und die Treppe wurde bewacht
guckt mal
komm nicht vorbei
hehehe
Du kannst hier nicht einfach vorbeigehen.
Jetzt erstmal unauffällig putzen, unauffällig putzen.
Hoch, was jetzt, was jetzt, was jetzt?
Und jetzt habe ich mir gedacht, okay, Katze ist abgelenkt.
Katze ist abgelenkt, jetzt kannst du vorbeigehen.
Jetzt kannst du vorbeigehen.
Das geht auf gar keinen Fall.
Auf gar keinen Fall.
Interessiert mich nicht, interessiert mich nicht.
Wie du gehst vorbei.
Erwischt, exposed.
Exposed.
Jetzt kriege ich erstmal einen Finger gebissen.
Und jetzt denkst du sich, okay, ich habe keinen Bock mehr.
Blob.
So, das war das.
Dann habe ich noch den gehabt.
Ja gut, das ist Hochkant, Hochkant ist doof.
Da lag sie einfach nur besonders niedlich rum.
Aber das, das, das nächste ist wirklich, das nächste ist wirklich white people blanket, blanket happy oder so.
Ich schleiche mich an die Katze an.
Achtung.
Jetzt hat sie mich gesehen.
Ja, so ein Feinie, gell.
Ja.
Wow, ja.
Wohnort liegt in den Augen der Katzen.
Gib es zu.
Wohnort liegt hier, guck mal, ich sehe es genau, ich sehe es genau.
Jetzt ist der Wohnort liegt.
In dem Moment.
Wow.
Wie sie plinzeln.
Plinzel, Plinzel.
Das heißt ja, das heißt ja Zwischenkatze, wir tun uns nichts.
Jetzt mach weiter, mach weiter.
Ja, habe ich gedacht, muss ich euch mal zeigen.
Exzellent.
Jetzt mache ich das iPhone wieder ab.
Nicht, dass der im Hintergrund noch auf einmal Bilder von mir indiziert, die er nicht indexiert, die er nicht indexieren soll.
Die ist, ist schon recht dick.
Ja.
Aber die war von Anfang an dick.
Und das geht auch nicht mehr weg.
Aber das passt auch, das passt auch.
Schon in Ordnung.
Pepofet Katze.
Der Desktop ist top.
Was da immer so viele Probleme mit haben.
Was ist denn im Ordner Trade?
Passive Exile Trade.
China steckt aus den Flaschen, haben wir sogar live im Stream gemacht.
Es hängt immer ein bisschen davon ab, was du für welche bekommst, mit welchem Firmware Stand.
Ja, aber wozu, wozu
hat man denn einen Desktop, wenn man ihn nicht benutzt?
Gute Leuchtmittel mit der Hue Bridge Tool.
Nee, keine Ahnung, ich hab keine Hue.
Ich mach das alles über Home Assistant
mit, ähm, den unterschiedlichsten Sachen.
Das meiste RGB-LED Zeug ist
ist LiFeX.
Aber die sind ehrlich gesagt zu teuer.
Wobei Hue ist auch teuer genug.
Wo wir gerade dabei sind, ich brauche Katzenbrunnenfilter brauche ich.
Runde, Runde Katzenbrunnenfilter brauche ich.
So was hier.
Pet Fountain Replacement Filter.
Genau das, die habe ich in dem hier stehen.
Excellent.
Übrigens Katzenbrunnen ist das Beste,
was ihr eurer Katze holen könnt.
Katzen stehen,
Katzen stehen
auf laufendes Wasser,
oder auf fließendes Wasser.
Und entweder
so was aus Keramik oder so was hier.
Ich hab so was jetzt hier am Start gerade.
Da stehen die voll drauf.
Ja, das Problem ist, bei meinem Home Assistant
leak ich zu viel, wenn ich den zeige.
Was filtern die Filter?
Das Wasser.
Da fällt ja auch mal irgendwie Staub rein,
Haare rein und sonst was.
Also Katzenbrunnen ist geil.
Alle Katzen, die ich bisher hatte,
mochten Katzenbrunnen.
Für Stonehenge 15 Monate.
Dankeschön für die Hypersubscription.
Lieber Regenwasser
als Leitungswasser.
Ja, Regenwasser ist ja auch super spannend.
Die letzte hat ja auch draußen
immer aus den Blumentöpfen
den Dreckwasser gesoffen.
Katzen mögen aber Fließwasser.
Deswegen stehen so viele Katzen auch drauf,
aus dem Wasserhahn zu trinken.
Was sagst du dazu, dass Pogchamp
eigentlich nur für Pogchamp
und Pogchamp für Pogchamp
und Pogchamp
Und was sagst du dazu, dass Pogchamp
entfernt wurde? Ich habe mich da am Anfang
des Streams lange zu ausgelassen und irgendwie
auf viel zu viel drumrum gelabert.
Weil mir da zu viel zu
eingefallen ist. Wie gesagt
ich kann es nachvollziehen aus der Sicht
von Twitch, dass sie es gemacht haben.
Ich persönlich
mich hat überhaupt nicht interessiert,
was das für ein Typ ist.
Letztendlich geht es mir um die Aussage des Emotes.
Ich wusste vorher auch nicht, was das für
Das interessiert doch überhaupt nicht, was das für ein Mensch ist hinter dem Emote, sondern mich interessiert eigentlich nur das Emote.
Heißt, ich find's doof, dass das Emote weg war und das aktuelle PogChamp gefällt mir auf jeden Fall nicht.
Ich kann nicht schreiben, das aktuelle PogChamp gefällt mir nicht.
Man hätte eher das da nehmen sollen, das hier.
Das ist, das finde ich ganz ehrlich, das ist noch, aber das ist halt nicht von Twitch selbst, das ist noch am ehesten passend von den Standard Emotes.
Also von den, von der Twitch-TV-Standard-Emote.
Ja, ich weiß, das wechselt jeder, jeden Viertel. Den mag ich auch nicht.
Ich hoffe, es kommt halt mal ein gutes, gutes PogChamp.
Der ist aber weniger, der ist aber weniger PogChamp-ig, der Typ.
Der hat zwar einen PogChamp-Bauch, aber er selbst ist kein gutes PogChamp-Emote.
PogFisch. Ja, so ein PogFisch wäre auch nicht verkehrt.
Also wie gesagt, ich fühle mich dadurch jetzt nicht besser, dass das Emote weg ist.
Mir fehlt einfach der alte PogChamp.
Aber wie gesagt, ich verstehe es aus Twitch-sicht, dass man das macht.
Wenn man damit nichts zu tun haben will, ist okay, verstehe ich.
Aber mir persönlich war es egal, was das für ein Typ ist hinter dem Emote.
Welt gerettet.
Und das ist auch ein PogChamp.
Aber mir persönlich war es egal, was das für ein Typ ist hinter dem Emote.
Welt gerettet, genau.
Exquisite.
Erstmal 85€ ausgegeben für unsinnig viel Ram Raspberry Pi.
Inklusive Netzteil, was ich eigentlich nicht bräuchte, weil ich noch genug 5V Netzteile habe.
Aber...
Ich habe ja Prime-Subs.
Da kann ich mir das leisten.
So Leute, wir raten.
Wir machen nochmal das übliche Prime-Sub-Raten.
Was heißt das übliche?
Wir haben das jetzt 5 mal gemacht oder so, über 3 Jahre verteilt.
Was meint ihr?
Bei wie viel Subs sind wir gerade?
Rat-Champ?
Oh, alles falsch.
Ah, fast!
Nein, 400€ wäre nice.
Ne, doch tatsächlich, 280€ sind wir.
Richtig, 280€.
Hättest du keinen Sub gehabt, hätte ich dich jetzt eingegiftet.
280€ sind wir.
XD, XD, wem soll ich einen Sub giften?
Was?
Wie kommst du da drauf?
Inside my flow.
Wie kommst du drauf, dass ich das bin?
Kegweight?
Also, XD, XD, wem soll ich einen Sub giften?
Wasserfreak, ok.
Alles klar.
Aber verschenken.
Stufe 1.
Kannste sogar neue Emotes, wir haben sogar neue Emotes, die kannst du jetzt verwenden.
Ich hab's ja geschafft innerhalb von irgendwie jetzt, wie lang bin ich Partner?
Eineinhalb Jahre oder so.
Ich hab's jetzt geschafft.
Ich glaub, wir haben 28 Emote-Slots, hab ich letztens mal gezählt, ne?
Und ich hab's geschafft bisher, aber auch nur weil der Patrick mitgemacht hat,
drei sinnvolle Emotes reinzumachen.
Der Rest ist ja füll.
Ich guck mal, Leute, ich guck mal kurz, wie viel Emote-Slots wir haben.
Ich glaub, 28 waren's.
Ihr Präferenzen, Partner, das ist übelst versteckt auf Twitch, ne?
Emote.
Braucht ja immer drei Stunden, bis ich das gefunden hab, Emote.
Ja, genau, also.
18 plus 5 plus 5, 28, ja.
Sollte sich mal vorstellen.
28 Emote-Slots und ganze drei Emotes schon drinne.
Oder, ne, ich glaub, drinne haben wir...
Ich glaub, drinne haben wir sogar mehr.
Ich glaub, drinne haben wir sieben oder so.
Ja, sieben Stück.
Aber davon ist halt viel Füllkram.
Mit 28 kannst du ein 5-mal-5-Bild machen.
Ne, das ist sogar eine coole Idee.
So, wupp, eins, zwei, drei, vier.
Ne, ein 5-mal-5-Pock-Champ kann ich nicht machen.
Dann werd ich gebannt, wenn ich einen Pock-Champ mach.
Was?
Hallo, Max, ist die Grafikkarte kaputt,
wenn ich im Bild rote Streifen habe?
Sowohl am Laptop-Bildschirm als auch auf einem externen Bildschirm.
Nee, mir geht nicht mehr.
Das klingt auf jeden Fall nicht gut.
Vielleicht ist auch nur der RAM auf der Grafikkarte kaputt,
aber das ist ja im Prinzip Teil von der Grafikkarte.
Das klingt definitiv nicht gesund, wenn du rote Streifen hast.
Wird man drauf trippen? Ja, deine Grafikkarte ist kaputt.
Kann natürlich noch an was anderem liegen,
aber das klingt sehr nach im Arsch.
Rote Streifen.
Es sei denn, du spielst Farmas mit rotem T-...
Oh, das war schlecht.
Ich mach den Satz gar nicht fertig.
Der war so schlecht.
Das muss man gar nicht weiter ausführen.
Pains-Champ.
Ja, siehste mal, Leute.
Sogar Pains-Champ dürfte man jetzt nicht mehr verwenden,
weil es der gleiche Typ ist.
Es gibt auch kein Pains-Champ mehr.
Boah, das ist anstrengend.
Ich muss die ganzen Champ-Emotes ersetzen.
Hack wait.
Es gibt kein Paws-Champ mehr, kein Pok-Champ,
kein Pains-Champ.
Alles weg.
Sucked.
Reaction-Empfehlung.
Das kenn ich.
Das kenn ich schon.
Das haben wir, glaub ich, sogar schon mal geguckt.
Darfst du die auch nicht mehr auf Twitch zeigen?
Nee, ich glaube, das steht
nicht in den Policies drin,
dass man das nicht darf.
Hast du schon zu Ende geschoppt?
Naja, die restlichen Sachen,
die ich brauche, interessieren, glaube ich,
keinen mehr großartig.
Ich bräuchte beispielsweise noch Katzenstreu.
Das muss ich aber nicht im Stream kaufen.
Hat jemand von euch,
meine Frage, hat jemand von euch diesen
Elgato Cam Link?
Taugt das?
Weil ich habe hier noch eine ganz gute Sony
Kamera.
So ein Sony Camcorder.
Und
ich habe mir
überlegt, ob ich den nicht per
Cam Link an meinen Rechner anschließe
für Bastelstream.
Weil aktuell mache ich ja Bastelstream mit
iPhone-Kamera.
Also sprich, das hier war, aber
ich habe es schon zugemacht. Also das, was
wir hier das letzte Mal hatten in den Videos,
das ist ja iPhone-Kamera.
Und da könnte ich
eigentlich mal eine Sony-Kamera.
Für verwenden.
Also sprich, das hier.
Das ist die iPhone-Kamera.
Es sieht auch okay aus. Aber ich könnte auch
mal eine Sony-Kamera dafür verwenden mit Cam Link.
Hat das einer von euch? Taugt das was?
Ich meine 130 Euro.
Ihr wisst ja,
mit den ganzen Prime-Subs,
ich habe es ja mittlerweile.
Aber ich will nicht unsinnig, nee, ernsthaft,
ich will nicht unsinnig Geld ausgeben.
Ich werde mir nicht anfangen,
jetzt 2,15K Karte zu verdienen.
Ich werde mir nicht anfangen, jetzt
2,15K Kameras hinzustellen.
Hast du die geholt? Okay.
Wäre es interessant
für die...
Was, nochmal. Wäre es für dich interessant,
mal ein Video
über das Thema Nass-Homeserver
aufsetzen zu machen? Frage aus
eigenem Interesse.
Ich wollte mal ein Nass-Bild machen,
aber das ist mittlerweile schon outdated.
Was ich jetzt mache?
Es gibt so viele Videos zu Nass.
Ich habe das Gefühl, die Leute
auf der... Der einzige Grund, warum
Leute sich damit beschäftigt sind,
weil sie sich ein Nass bauen wollen. Überall wo du guckst
Nass-Bild, Nass-Dings,
neuste Nass und
man hat das Gefühl, der einzige Anwendungszweck,
den die Leute daheim haben für sowas ist Nass.
Ich glaube, da gibt es schon genug.
Hol dir nicht den Cam Link,
lieber die HD60S.
Okay, das heißt, ich soll mir eine Capture-Card holen
und dann von der Kamera per HDMI
in die Capture-Card.
Das könnte ich auch machen. Ich habe ja eine Capture-Card.
Das könnte ich auch machen, ja.
Ja, genau.
Nach der tiefer Halb-Affe sehe ich auch so.
Brauche ich eigentlich nicht machen, gibt es echt genug.
Cam Link ist Schrott. Okay, dann kaufe ich den nicht.
Was meinen Sie?
Ist die 1599 HD-Video-Capture besser?
Meinen die auch, die ist besser?
Ganz klar, ja, denke ich auch.
Das da mit Sicherheit größer das da.
Ganz bestimmt.
Oder der Zluke.
Zasluke.
Game-Capture-Card.
Das ist so ein typischer China-Produkt,
das erkennt man schon an der Überschrift.
Zasluke, Game-Capture-Card, 4K HDMI,
Capture-Card, 1000-HP-Luken-Inter,
das ist ein China-Produkt.
Auch die Beschreibung, so typische China-Produkt-Beschreibung.
Und auch die Bilder,
haben die in China nur einen Photoshop-Chinamann,
der diese Bilder macht für die Produktdinger.
Das sieht alles gleich aus.
Zasluke.
Oh, habe ich das Mist erzählt?
Sind das gar keine Chinesen?
Doch, definitiv.
Die Webseite sieht so dermaßen kacke aus,
das müssen Chinesen sein.
Ja, Shang Tsang.
Hui Kuo Pian.
Technology, limited.
Aber limited.
Und About Us,
oder so ein Business-Typ.
Was hat der Typ eigentlich für einen Hals?
Das sieht nicht gesund aus.
Zasluke.
Wenn keine Basteln kam, schriebst du ein Katzencam.
Das geht nicht.
Die liegt immer an so Sachen, die lassen sich schlecht filmen.
So, Leute.
Das mit dem Mikrofon macht mich immer noch fertig,
dass ich das nicht gesehen habe die letzten zwei Wochen.
Obwohl es die ganze Zeit auf meinem Schreibtisch stand.
Gibt es irgendeine Krankheit,
dass man selektiv Sachen nicht sieht?
Ernsthaft?
Habe ich irgendwie Gehirn-Schaden oder so?
Oh, ich habe das Gefühl,
ich habe das Gefühl,
von meinem Image,
ohne Kopie.
Was hast du nicht gesehen?
Mein Mikrofon!
Patrick! Vielleicht kannst du dich noch erinnern,
ich habe vor zwei Wochen
dem Stream mal eben gesagt,
ich suche meinen Blueti-Mikrofon.
Heute habe ich es zufälligerweise gefunden.
Und es stand die ganze Zeit
mitten auf nur einem Schreibtisch.
Links am Rand vor meinem Schreibtisch stand es.
Und ich habe es nicht gesehen!
mal danach geguckt haben und ich bin ich ich wie gesagt ich hätte geschworen
es steht da nicht aber naja also es gibt ja viel weniger
erklärungen für dass es da nicht stand also das stand die ganze zeit da ich
hab's bloß nicht gesehen ja in 30 jahren kann ich den rennen gehen exquisite
wobei ich nicht bis 67 arbeite das können sie sich abschmecken
zoomeeting habe ich nicht nein nein nein teams teams wir haben kein zoom wir haben teams
der ober boomer bei uns auf der arbeit der ist jetzt weg der hat das letzte geschäftsjahr nicht
oder das ist nicht geschäftsjahr das letzte jahr nicht über also doch doch doch das muss man der
heutigen zeit ja aufpassen doch klar hat er das überlebt aber er hat es insofern nicht
überlebt er ist nicht mehr bei uns in der firma der ist nicht mehr da den haben sie
vertraglich verlängert also unser ober boomer ist weg wir haben aber noch genug genug andere
nicht jetzt unbedingt direkt bei mir im team also allgemein wenn man in etwas übergreifenderen
meetings hockt die leute die eindeutig noch nie online spiele gespielt haben und dementsprechend
absolut nicht in der lage sind sowohl sich an ein logisches verhalten normales verhalten im
voice chat zu halten oder sich zu muten oder push to talk zu machen oder ein gescheites
mikrofon zu holen oder ihr mikrofon nicht in bobs zu schieben unglaublich was du da teilweise
für leute hast ja auf jeden das lohnt sich extrem stubenhocker also gerade wenn du ein stubenhocker
bist lohnt sich das extrem ja kommt drauf an auf welche lohnt es sich deiner nach vier
tage die woche zu arbeiten ja wie gesagt extrem lohnt sich das du hast zwar auf dem papier
nur einen tag mehr wochenende aber es ist gefühlt fast doppelt so viel weil normalerweise
ist es so und ich glaube das werden die meisten kennen es sei es sei denn ihr seid jemand der
so richtig so richtig krass karriere stellts macht so nach dem motto mich stört es auch
nicht wenn ich am sonntag wenn mich beim sonntag mein chef anrufen dann freue ich mich sogar
dass ich zeigen kann was ich tolles der firma bringen kann gibt so leute soll jeder machen
wie er will aber bei mir war es halt immer so freitag bist du halt geschafft von der
woche und machst erstmal eigentlich nichts mehr großartig zumindest wenn du 30 plus
bist samstag musst du dann ein paar sachen machen die dort machen muss wo du die woche
über keine zeit für hattest das heißt der halbe samstag ist weg den restlichen samstag
kannst du dann easy machen was du willst sonnach schläfst du auch aus samstag hast
auch ausgeschlafen ab sonntag mittag denkst du im endeffekt schon scheiße morgen gehts
wieder auf die arbeit so und das ganze problem hast du nicht wenn du montags auf frei hast
du bist viel entspannter den kompletten freitag über weil du weißt jetzt hast du erstmal
eine ganze weile frei den ganzen freitag auch da wo du arbeiten musst dann kannst du samstag
ausschlafen machst du in ruhe das was du machen musst machst samstag den restlichen tag wo
du bock drauf hast machst sonnach komplett den tag wo du bock drauf hast es sei denn
du hast irgendwelche familiäre verpflichtungen oder so und du machst montag komplett tag
wo du bock drauf hast und montagabend denkst du dir dann gar nicht scheiße ich muss morgen
wieder arbeiten gehen sondern du denkst dir ja gut ich bin jetzt erholt habe jetzt eigentlich
zweieinhalb drei tage gemacht worauf ich bock hatte jetzt können wir da ein bisschen arbeiten
so läuft zumindest bei mir deswegen also ich finde das super vier tage die woche ich mache
halt freitag samstag montag es gibt auch leute die schwören darauf noch irgendwann mal donnerstag
oder so zu machen oder mit mittwoch habe ich gerade im chat geschrieben ja ja und captain
peng hat natürlich komplett recht ich mache mal kurz den hier weg es kommt mir manchmal
echt so vor ja ist so der grund warum ich montags freigenommen habe ist genau der ich
wollte mich ursprünglich montags ja ein bisschen mein geschäft kümmern ja zum beispiel mit
irgendwelchen sponsorsachen reden oder irgendwelche sachen klären ob man nicht irgendwas machen kann
oder sonst wie und montag sind die leute hat noch super motiviert dementsprechend nerven
die leute montags auf der arbeit am meisten aber wenn du selbst was willst von irgendwelche
leuten ist montags der beste tag deswegen habe ich montags freigenommen
so war jetzt das bild hier gerade mit den ganzen boomern drinnen ja richtig wird
gemp richtig wird gemp würdest du als quereinsteiger in den lehrer beruf
ne ne würde ich nicht machen mir macht es zwar spaß azubis ab und zu was beizubringen aber
zubi sind auch schon im alter wo sie nicht mehr ganz so nervig sind ne das liegt daran warum ich
das nicht machen würde folgendes erstens und das wisst ihr alle mag ich keine menschen
jugendlich und kinder schon mal gar nicht und in dem alter sind die auch ultra nervig also
32 stunden sind es bei mir die woche 30 stunden das ist das das stimmt aber es hält sich in
grenzen muss ja auch ein ticken weniger steuern bezahlen wobei es bei mir egal ist ich bestalle
mittlerweile ich spritze steuersatz vollkommen irrelevant aber normalerweise sollte man eigentlich
ein bisschen weniger steuern bezahlen das problem ist dass man zumindest in deutschland schon quasi
auch leute zu denen ich jetzt nicht sagen würde die sind reich spritzen steuersatz bezahlen
müssen das ist kein weird flex das ist eher scheiße in deutschland dass du als jemand der
gar nicht viel geld verdient spritzen steuersatz bezahlen muss aber guck mal ich glaube was sind
es 48 prozente spritzen steuersatz ab wann ab wann ab wie viel 42 prozent nicht 68 hier
hallo es ist sicherlich nicht wenig geld das will ich nicht sagen aber man kann nicht ernsthaft
behaupten dass 57.000 euro reich sind ich weiß dass das viel geld ist für viele leute aber
trotzdem ich finde es nicht gerechtfertigt dass man mit 57.000 spritzen steuersatz bezahlen muss
ziehen die schweiz easy beschaffen wir den job in der schweiz ich bin morgen am starte
wäre ich nett weil ich habe hier mein haus und gestellts am start aber prinzipiell ja ich
meine das kann es doch nicht sein ernsthaft ab wann fändest du den spritzen steuersatz gerechtfertigt
vielleicht 100k aber ehrlich gesagt aber ehrlich gesagt würde ich sogar sogar noch
einen ticken höher ansetzen ich bin an meinem spritzen steuersatz sollten die leute zahlen
wo man wirklich auch sagen wird die sind reich ja und reich ist für mich jemand der quasi
sagen könnte ach easy was juckt mich ich kaufe mir jetzt irgendwie 80k bmw einfach mal so
weil ich bock drauf hab oder irgendwas ihr wisst dass ich keine autos mich für keine autos interessiere also war das jetzt
wahrscheinlich blödes beispiel oder oder reich ist für mich jemand der sagen kann ich falls mal
zwei monate einfach mal so in urlaub irgendwo irgendwo hin und ohne arbeiten zu müssen sonst
wie und ohne irgendwas zu machen in irgendein luxusgebiet oder so würde ich auch nicht machen
aber das sind also leute die sind reich die haben echt viel kohle also ich wie gesagt ich
finde ich finde es nicht gerechtfertigt dass man als gefühlt oder was heißt als gefühlt
als faktisch mit letzt verbliebene mittelstand menge spritzen steuersatz bezahlen muss das war
früher mal mehr also anteilmäßig aber schwachsinnig anteilmäßig also als vom verhältnis war das früher
mal deutlich mehr und ich finde ich finde es zu niedrig ehrlich gesagt ja ne wie gesagt
würde ich nicht machen wenn jetzt eine irgendwie 15k im monat verdient oder so okay dann lasse
mir das irgendwie gefallen ja aber wie meinst du das ich bin super entspannt am wochenende
ich bin mittlerweile super entspannt am wochenende war mir echt ich habe es mittlerweile hingekriegt
dass wenn ich freitags mich auslocke ich mir keine gedanken um die arbeit mache ist echt so
höchstens höchstens über sachen an denen ich spaß dran habe
das ist richtig genau er wahrscheinlich kommt einem deswegen auch viel entspannter vor
also war zwei tagen nur ich finde zwei tage müssen gar nicht sein aber zwei tagen sind
natürlich auch cool aber bei zwei tagen ist dann wahrscheinlich schon ein bisschen deutlicher
zu spüren mit dem geld das ist richtig ich bin also ich bin seitdem viel entspannter ich
würde nicht unbedingt sagen motivierter ich bin ich bin nicht der typ um großartig motiviert
zu sein für sachen die mich persönlich eben nicht so ja aber ich bin auf jeden fall deutlich
entspannter konzentrierter und was dazu kommt seit den ganzen home office geschichte erst
recht ich glaube ich habe noch nie so viel am stück machen können wie seit home office
am start ist wie viele stunden 30 stunden ähm was was was soll ich von denen halten
die sind halt auch da ja lieber dem chat fast bei bringen ist echt so ich bringe lieber
dem chat fast bei als irgendwelche leute in der schule ähm patrick ich cap dir voll
und ganz recht das ist das ist tatsächlich so wenn du also es müssen noch nicht mal
schlaue leute in form von high IQ big brain sein es müssen leute sein die sich für das
thema interessieren dann macht es spaß wenn du den irgendwelche des interessierten kack
noobs rumhocken hast die entweder entweder gnadenlos zu dumm sind oder meistens einfach
nur absolut kein bock haben dann macht es keinen spaß ja die kombination ist doch verständlich
oder das eine hat doch mit dem anderen überhaupt nichts zu tun es sitzen ja keine 360 leute
bei mir daheim
360.000 leute was hast du direkt nach deiner ausbildung verdient lasst mal in mich gehen
ich glaube sechst ne ich bin mir jetzt nicht mal sicher ich glaube 36.000 es könnte aber
auch ein bisschen weniger gewesen sein das war noch beim provider wo ich meine ausbildung
gemacht habe da war ich ja da nicht so lange
top idee wieso magst du kinder nicht ich hab gesagt ich mag alle menschen nicht mir ist
egal ob jung ob alt ob schwarz oder weiß ich mag überhaupt keine menschen kinder natürlich
besonders nicht weil die schreien auch noch rum also die meisten auf jeden fall nee was
soll ich denn da ist es nicht da wo unge ist da glaub schon ja ich mein ernsthaft kann
es doch nicht sein
ich ist wer winrar lizenz kaufen wer winrar lizenz kauft ist doof der ist nicht reich
also vielleicht reich an geld aber nicht reich an gehirnmasse ja gut die leute sind
teilweise auch komplett detached von der realität das ist auch so ein ding was ich
bei der ganzen corona geschichte immer ein bisschen bisschen lustig finde wenn du dann
von leuten hörst die finanziell ihr komplettes leben ausgesorgt haben und von diesen leuten
dann hörst also stelle ich stelle euch mal vor ihr seid jetzt irgendwie einen becker
oder irgendwie ein friseur der quasi jetzt nie großartig im geld schwimmt aber gut
über die runden kommen und im prinzip so kurz kurz vor komplett nerven zusammenbruch
und pleite steht so und da kommen dann leute an und stellen sich hin so nach dem motto
wir müssen jetzt alle zusammenhalten und das ist alles nicht so wild und und wir schaffen
das schon und ja aber ich bin jemand der hat eigentlich für immer ausgesorgt das wirkt
dann halt finde ich ein bisschen überheblich an manchen stellen ja
im chat kann ich ja ich aber dienstag mittwoch erster freitag
nein ich wirklich da bin ich da da bin ich der falsche typ für mein karriere tipp ist
dass ich alle karriere tipps gekonnt ignoriert habe bisher mein alter chef der hat der hat
mir immer erzählt was wir für geile karrieremöglichkeiten haben und er hat der wollte partoo nicht
einsehen dass ich keinen bock auf karriere in in der in der firma wo ich arbeite der
hat auch immer erzählt ja was wir für möglichkeiten haben von von irgendwelchen projekt management
bis irgendwelche leitungen in dieser geschichte man könnte doch auch mal vielleicht irgendwie
als eigentlich gar nicht drüber nachdenken immer gesagt ne will ich nicht will ich nicht
will ich nicht da kam an ja es gibt doch jetzt auch bei uns neue experten rollen da könnte
man hier und da und sonst wie also wie gesagt mein alter chef mein neuer chef lässt mich
damit glücklicherweise halbwegs so ich glaube der weiß dass ich nicht will
ja ne will ich nicht der hauptsächliche grund ist auch weil ich keinen bock habe mehr stonks
sachen zu machen als technik und außerdem umso mehr karriere gedönst man macht umso
mehr involviert ist man auch mit der jeweiligen firma und umso mehr muss man da halt eben
auch so so engaged sein ja bin ich nicht also ich arbeite da ich versuche das was ich zu
machen ich versuche das was ich mache auch gut zu machen so aus technischen aspekten
weil er auch letztendlich dann gewissen so gewissen qualitäts anspruch an mich selbst
habe was ich bastel ich mag zwar an sich nicht nicht sonderlich ordentlich sein wenn ich
teilweise die amazon karton stapel sehen könntet aber wenn es bei mir um technik programmieren
und computer krams geht da habe ich schon so eine gewisse so einen eigensinnigen ordnungs
trieb irgendwie schwer zu erklären also sprich ich habe kein problem wenn die wohnung unordentlich
ist aber ich habe ein problem wenn das was ich programmieren unordentlich ist kann ich
auch nicht genau erklären ist aber so ja aber ansonsten ist mir es eigentlich ziemlich
egal was die firma macht wo ich arbeite ich weiß es soweit ich wissen muss ja logisch
weil ich muss ja wissen was produkte machen aber es kann keiner von mir erwarten dass
ich da irgendwie dahinter stehen würde und sagen jawoll das ist der geilste laden überhaupt
und ich freue mich ich bin froh dass ich hier arbeiten darf ist ja wozu wenn die morgen
sagen max wir brauchen dich nicht dann bin ich weg fertig dann sagen die max hier leck
mich tschüss und dann kicken die mich raus das ist vollkommen egal das heißt warum warum
sollte ich irgendwie da ja so vertrauen und und hype in die firma investieren wenn sie
das bei mir auch nicht machen also ich finde man muss nicht da unbedingt da komplett dahinter
stehen und das geil finden was die firma macht es reicht voll und ganz wenn man seine arbeit
gut macht und letztendlich wollen sie ja das wollen beide seiten das gleiche man will
geld haben dafür und die wollen deine arbeitskraft zu geld machen fertig das ist ja das wo sich
einer in dem video was ich gemacht habe wo wo wo einer geschrieben hat das wäre bei
ihnen nicht so wo ich halt wo ich halt echt mal richtig hart kacken musste als ich das
gelesen habe da hat er was geschrieben das kommt noch finde
was ich verbrenne hier genau der da der da also ich habe ich habe im video mehr oder
weniger das gesagt was ich ja auch im stream gerade gesagt habe er schreibt als hier also
unseren mitarbeitern ist es richtig wichtig sich mit dem arbeitgeber und den aufgaben
zu identifizieren andere mitarbeiter will ich ehrlich gesagt auch gar nicht es geht
bei der it meiner meinung noch null darum einfach nur geld zu machen ohne dass ich
hinter meinen aufgaben stehen will ich gar nicht also ich gehe mal davon aus er ist der
chef ich gehe mal davon aus er ist der chef gute it der lassen sich weniger vom geld
sondern mehr davon leiten dass die arbeit beides beides das ist nicht komplett es ist
nicht komplett von der hand zu weisen ja mir ist es auch lieber es ist ein laden wo man
gut mit den leuten klarkommt wo es gute arbeitsbedingungen gibt gute raumbedingungen da verzichte ich
auch auf ein bisschen weniger geld das ist richtig aber dass es null um geld geht ist
nur wirklich nicht so es geht primär ums geld selbstverständlich auch bei einem itler
der arbeitet geht es primär ums geld wenn man jetzt seine eigene firma hat seit es
mal dahingestellt und ja es ist super und es sollte auch so sein dass man das gerne
macht was man macht aber die arbeit gerne machen und die aufgaben gut finden und da
dahinter stehen ist was komplett anderes als hinter der firma zu stehen und sagen die firma
ist geil also es gibt ja durchaus aufgaben die man gut finden kann überlegt euch mal
zum beispiel ihr würdet für den rüstungsunternehmen arbeiten und ihr werdet jemand der hätte
keine ahnung werdienst verweigern und habt somit krieg nicht so gut dann könnt ihr sagen
das unternehmen an sich geht mir am arsch vorbei aber die arbeit macht mir trotzdem
spaß das ist eine kombination die ist durchaus möglich es kann sein dass die arbeit da richtig
cool ist aber ihr sagt hey hinter der firma stehe ich nicht und das finde ich vollkommen
ok das kann doch keiner von den leuten verlangen solange die ihre arbeit gut machen es soll
es doch vollkommen in ordnung es kann doch keiner von mir verlangen dass ich jetzt persönlich
überzeugt davon bin dass der laden der geilste auf der welt ist so und das hier das erste
muss ich halt sagen also ich finde das vollkommen in ordnung was er geschrieben hat muss ich
auch noch mal dazu sagen ich finde das super dass mit das auch mal leute in die comments
schreiben dass man das alles anders sehen kann die sache ist halt die er ist wahrscheinlich
der chef so und jetzt überlegt euch mal jetzt überlegt euch mal ihr seid der chef und ihr
geht zu einem eurer mitarbeiter und fragt die jetzt sagen sie mal herr müller was denken
sie von unserer firma also wenn das euer chef abteilungsleiter ist wahrscheinlich der
oberchef da fragt was sagt ihr da als antwort sagt ihr alter so ein kackladen aber die arbeit
ist ganz nice oder sagt ihm das was er hören will also 99 prozent der leute der patrick
vielleicht mal ausgenommen den schätze ich nicht so einer sagt ihm wahrscheinlich auch
alter scheißladen aber der ernsthaft 99 prozent der leute sagen das was der chef hören will
und der regel will der chef das hören was er selber permanent sagt also wenn man sagt
wir sind die geilsten wir sind die besten wir sind in dem und dem bereich die marktführer
und keiner hat so gute produkte wie wir dann sagen die leute das dann sagen die leute das
und dementsprechend denkt er das auch aber ganz ehrlich wenn die leute untereinander
reden sagen die was ganz was anderes by the way captain sieg also ist es bei mir auch
ich bin so weit ich bin richtig lost hier im chat gerade das ist aber auch so beim direkten
chef sage ich das auch wenn es mir auf den sack geht aber der hat da ähnliche ähnliche
probleme teilweise ich weiß auch nicht ob der alles geil findet was wir machen keine
ahnung glaube ich ehrlich gesagt nicht und dem sage ich auch an dem sage ich auch wie
es ist das ist übrigens der von dem ich mal im battle viel gameplay hatte ist jetzt mein
chef weiß gar nicht ob es jemals gebracht habe und dem sage ich das auch wenn mir was
nicht gefällt aber ohne mist wenn der abteilungsleiter oder in den forstanz typ da letztens habe
ich habe ich das habe ich euch doch sogar erzählt letztens oder letztens hat mich der
neue forst weiß ich ob er forstand ist oder oder nur oder nur kompletter bereichsleiter
also irgendein irgendein high high stocks top management dude bei uns hat einen termin
hat mich zu einem termin eingeladen und wollte von mir sachen wissen und habe erst mal was
will der von mir warum lädt er mich ein ich kenne den typ nicht ich habe damit nichts
zu tun was will er dann ausgerechnet von mir ja bis ich dann bis ich dann bis ich dann
drauf gekommen bin warum warum wie das dazu gekommen ist der chef von meinem chef hat
gesagt oh nee der typ der will von uns was wissen haben wir nicht irgendeinen der ihm
das gut erklären kann und dann meinte mein chef so ja man könnte man den max hinschicken
also anscheinend muss ich irgendwie den eindruck machen die sachen recht diplomatisch verkaufen
zu können oder so keine ahnung und ich muss sagen das war wirklich nice das hätte ich
nicht gedacht der hat der hat dann quasi erzählt ja ist jetzt hier quasi hat es zwar quasi
neu angefangen und auf seiner management position bekommt er ja gar nicht gar nicht
mit wie die firma so tickt und deswegen wird er mich jetzt gerne mal ein paar sachen fragen
und das fand ich cool ich meine jetzt mal ernsthaft das musst du erst mal erkennen
in so einer position dass du selbst halt eben nicht das mit kriegst was wirklich passiert
weil die leuten immer schöne sachen erzählen und du auch viele sachen gar nicht mitbekommst
das fand ich gut ich hab dir ein paar sachen erzählt und über paar sachen habe ich auch
gemeckert und dann hat er am ende da hat er am ende den die wildcard gezogen und zwar
es gibt ja so fragen zum beispiel so wenn ihr euch irgendwo bewerbt so diese sache wo
sehen sie sich in zehn jahren das ist ja das was keiner wirkt bei mir gar nicht sicher
ob man das nicht wirklich noch fragt aber solche fragen sind die sind ja fies was willst
du da großartig drauf sagen und da hat er mich gefragt es passt mal er hat mich gefragt
ja herr max wenn sie wenn wenn ich ihn irgendwie so so ich krieg sie mir genau zusammen wenn
ich ihnen einen zauberstab geben würde was würden sie damit ändern wo ich jetzt mal
lachen und gesagt boah das ist jetzt aber eine komplizierte frage ich glaube ich hab
sogar aus spaß ich hab sogar aus spaß gefragt ob man mich nicht fragen kann wo ich mich
in zehn jahren sehe oder so das wäre mir einfacher fallen als da jetzt was drauf zu sagen und
ähm naja zumindest habe ich ihm dann auch wirklich was was was ernsthaftes gesagt also
wo ich wirklich denke dass das dass das sinnvoll ist und zwar habe ich ihm dann gesagt als
antwort drauf ja ich fände es ganz gut wenn mal alle beteiligten also aus allen aus allen
abteilungen aus allen richtungen mal alle ein bisschen mehr über ihren tellerrand gucken
würden ja also sprich wenn die leute die sich um die systeme kümmern müssen auch mal ein
bisschen sich dafür interessieren was ein programmierer für probleme hat oder entwickler
für probleme hat umgedreht vor allem halt auch weiß ich wenn entwickler mal ein bisschen
dafür interessieren würde wie der kram am ende überhaupt betrieben wird und das komplett
übergreifen anscheinend hat ihm das gefallen ja weil ich bin noch da aber war meine ehrliche
meinung ja ich konnte ich konnte natürlich jetzt nicht richtig dicke sachen raushauen
ja ganz ehrlich wenn ich wirklich den zauberstab hätte dann hätte ich dann würde ich wahrscheinlich
dafür sorgen erstmal alle leute mir auf den keks gehen würde ich weg zaubern aber das
war eigentlich noch eine ganz passende antwort denke ich oder übrigens dass da auf niemals
auf gar keinen fall würde ich das machen wollen management stonks sachen sind überhaupt
nicht mein ding wie wäre es mit einem onlyfans account account kente mit 36 genau ja aber
ich weiß jetzt noch sagen wollte zu diesem kommen natürlich sagen die mitarbeiter dort
ja klar beste beste unternehmen und bester chef und und tollste sache das ist nicht so
ganz realistisch was die dem erzählen was ist eigentlich ein normaler schlafgrund muss
wenn du arbeitest und auch normal immer der gleiche 22 bis 23 ins betten dann um acht
Uhr ungefähr aufstehen 7 30 acht Uhr aufstehen 8 30 beide mal ich bezweifle dass jeder verstanden
hat was dieser satz passt mal auf leute wer versteht diesen satz von jetzt alter was
den satz was genau wollt ihr von mir implementieren von übergabe übernahme prozesse für cs system
in zusammenarbeit abstimmen mit der produktion um den software life cycle zu automatisieren
alles klar oder wer versteht es nicht auf anhieb klar kann ich mir da was zusammen reimen
zu und wahrscheinlich stimmt das auch dann am ende halbwegs aber man kann es auch man
kann es auch klarer schreiben ja das ist einfach weiß ich gar nicht was was was cs systeme
sein sollen ja sie wollen dass man irgendeinen prozess einführt oder mitgestaltet in abstimmung
mit den sachen die jetzt schon da sind um eben den software life cycle zu automatisieren
also sprich von einführen bis supporten und von von selbst programmierter software wahrscheinlich
also man kann sich da einiges rein interpretieren aber ja so wirklich klar ist es nicht finde
ich und seine erklärung ist auch nicht so geil ich glaube jeder hat verstanden was
damit gemeint ist da habe ich so meine zweifel ccm ist übrigens konzentration konfigurations
wenn ich weiß habe ich mittlerweile rausgelegt drei monate dankeschön du sollst einen prozess
zur automatisierung des software life cycles implementieren hey wenn das so einfach ist
dann sagt es halt in normalen worten ja vielleicht war die stellenanzeige auch von ihm ja das
ist natürlich auch geil bringstruck hier nur in funktionale fragestellung und stellst
den transfer zu bestehenden funktionalen architektur modellen sicher da muss ich ehrlich sagen
ich habe keine ahnung was der satz bedeuten soll auch wenn er schreibt das ist komplett
normales deutsch und verständlich also ich muss ehrlich sagen ich habe wirklich keine
ahnung was das was das bedeuten soll du bringst struktur in funktionale fragestellung stellst
den transfer zu bestehenden funktional architektur modellen sicher keine ahnung legit keine
ahnung der chat versteht das natürlich alles das ist mir jetzt auch schon klar ist ja big
brain durch die ganzen prime subs ist der kopf immer weiter gewachsen das ist wahrscheinlich
euch allen klar nur mir nicht elementar exquisite wie kann man sowas nicht wissen ich kann
mir ja auch wieder ein paar sachen zusammen reihen also sprich wenn ihr mal man ist ansprechpartner
für für fragen wie die wie sachen gemacht werden sollen funktionieren und ich ich erkläre
das dann auch leuten die in bisherigen modellen arbeiten oder so keine ahnung es ergibt für
mich keinen sinn es ergibt es ergibt wirklich für mich keinen sinn ja und so leute sind
es dann halt auch die dann das dann halt wirklich glauben wenn ihnen das die mitarbeiter sagen
und in wirklich meinten dass die meisten mitarbeiter gar nicht so weil die sagen es halt nur weil
der chef sie gerade fragt dazu hier war auch ein geil hier war ein richtig geiles kommet
unter dem video was war richtig nice moment ja der typ ist geil der typ ist geil warum
nimmt man zur präsentation wie gut eine grafik auch zehn jahre später ist aufnahmen mit
low settings plaufilter gibt einen kühl realistischen look eigentlich sein unrealistischer cineastischer
look rein scheunen was ist das gibt es auch raus scheunen journalistische qualität passt
auf journalistische qualität journalistische qualität auf niveau einer schlechten schülerzeitung
in your face aber ganz im ernst wenn das wenn das seine einzigen kritikpunkte sind da kann
es ja nicht so schlimm sein einfach löschen ich finde es lustig ein steigert alter christian
becker
ja falls du da bist kannst du probierst lasst das einfach mal ausprobieren achso cs cs
kran hier die vrl
es kommt natürlich immer auf die region an aber mal ganz im ernst
was sind
was sind das
dafür dafür stehst du noch nicht mal auf das ist ja absolut lächerlich
achso ach moment das ist schon wenn steuern und so alles abgezogen sind
ja ok dann ist das als einstiegsgehalt gar nicht mal so scheiße ich mein ich hab wie
gesagt ich hab zum einstieg 36k gekriegt das ist natürlich jetzt dann nicht netto gewesen
einmal durch zwölf so und wenn du davon dann irgendwie keine ahnung noch mal noch mal
ein bisschen was abziehst dann
das kommt so ungefähr auf das hin ja
netto nichts proto ich kann mir den unterschied zwischen netto und proto immer folgendermaßen
merken netto denke ich immer negativ und an proto denke ich an plus an plus also an plus
für mehr oder big big oder plus ist proto aber ich merke mir immer big oder plus und
netto sowas wie negativ also dementsprechend es reicht ja wenn man sich eins merken kann
wenn man sich plus merken kann bei proto dann ist klar dass netto weniger ist beziehungsweise
das eine halt je nachdem weil wenn du was im laden kaufst sinds ja dann auch proto preise
weil mehrwertsteuer schon drin ist
wie gesagt so viel habe ich verdient aber deswegen redet man ja auch eigentlich nicht
in netto sondern in dem was auch im vertrag drin steht weil im vertrag steht ja eine deutlich
größere zahl weil das was rauskommt hängt ganz entscheidend davon ab bist du verheiratet
zum beispiel und andere verdienst du sonst doch irgendwie was also sprich man sollte
nicht netto gucken sondern was steht im vertrag drin dann kann man auch wirklich was sagen
wie gesagt ich habe 36k proto ganz am anfang nach der ausbildung bekommen das weiß ich
noch nach der ausbildung nach der ausbildung direkt nach der ausbildung
also wie gesagt ich habe damals das ist aber auch schon über zehn jahre ja bisschen bisschen
mehr als zehn jahr her das war das was ich verdient habe als erstes direkt nach der ausbildung
36k im jahr wo in der it verdient man eigentlich am meisten big brain data data science und
AI oder consulting ja was aber witzig ist dass die meisten consultants auch kein plan
haben consultants vom namen hört sich das ja immer so anders ist es jemand den konsultiert
man wenn man selbst nicht weiter weiß aber die meisten consultants wüsste ich keine
wozu ich die konsultieren sollte ja als cobalt entwickler könntest du tatsächlich auch viel
verdienen
da
Wir sehen uns
Wir sehen uns im nächsten stream
Lassen wir alle beim friseur vorbeigucken und bisschen voll spammen das sieht gerade so aus als macht er big brain sachen da braucht
Er noch ein bisschen spam im chat
Also bis morgen oder spätestens sonntag
Spätestens sonntag bis denn co ich habe schon noch von 6 auf 3